hello everyone welcome to the december
2021 ask me anything episode of the
mindscape podcast i'm your host sean
carroll
uh the podcast episode is being released
a little bit before december comes along
because it's the thanksgiving holiday
here in the united states uh so i'll be
traveling for that and then traveling
for a workshop directly afterward i
wanted to get to your ama questions
before i started traveling rather than
waiting until afterward
um
so you know that or long time listeners
know that i do take vacation for real
over the christmas holidays slash new
year's holidays so there's two weeks
when i will not have a real podcast
episode um and i will try to do a
holiday message short brief you know
thanking everyone for their support kind
of thing uh just before the holidays and
there will be no ask me anything episode
for january so no ask me anything
episode with questions asked at the end
of december answers given at the
beginning of january so this is it this
is the last ask me anything episode for
this year the next call will be near the
end of january again those of you who
are long time listeners know if you want
to ask a question for the ask me
anything episode the important thing is
to support mindscape on patreon you can
go to patreon.com
sean m carroll and you sign up there
dollar or whatever you want per episode
of mindscape we'll get you both ad-free
versions of the podcast as well as the
ability to ask questions for the monthly
ask me anything episodes it used to be
back in the old days when it was just a
few of us around the fire that everyone
who asked a question got it answered
we've grown since then
can't be quite the same anymore but i do
try to pick the best questions in terms
of things i can give interesting answers
to do not feel bad if you ask a question
that i don't get around to it it's me
it's not you don't worry about it
the other thing of course is i'd like to
remind people we have a
web page for the podcast preposterous
universe.com
podcast and all the mindscape episodes
are there you can search them there's a
wonderful little search tool you can
search not only the titles and my show
notes but also complete transcripts of
all the podcasts transcripts that are
paid for
by the patreon supporters we have here
and of course you can also get links to
the people who are talking their web
pages
their publications whatever it is and
the final thing which i never remember
to mention but i always remember it when
i'm not recording is that we do
appreciate reviews of the podcast on
itunes and elsewhere you know getting
good itunes reviews helps you get more
visible to other people who might like
to listen to podcasts so as good as the
podcast is don't hog it for yourself
share it around share the word that
mindscape is a good thing let me see
anything else nothing else right now i
have a lot of packing to do there is a
trip coming up and a lot of questions to
get to so let's go
[Music]
joy kolbeck says why are black holes
bald this is of course in reference to
the famous statement by john wheeler
that a black hole has no hair uh an idea
that was uh
semi-rigorized by roger penrose into the
uh no hair what we call the no hair
theorem but a mathematician would not
really call it a theorem it's not been
proven yet because of course you don't
know the ultimate laws of physics yet
what does it mean to prove something
unless you have some good axioms now
what you can do is assume some laws of
physics like it's just general
relativity plus electromagnetism and
then you can prove
a no-hair kind of theorem that says that
once you make a black hole unlike a
planet or a star which has all sorts of
interesting features on it all black
holes settle down
to a uniform configuration it's always
the same kind of configuration given the
mass the charge and the spin of the
black hole there's no other hair on a
black hole other than that it's not like
you have continents and oceans or
something like that like a planet does
so why is joy's question uh you know why
questions in physics are always tricky
it depends on what assumptions you're
going to start with here but the way i
like to think about the black hole
situation is
it's entropy it's usually entropy that
is at the heart of these kinds of
questions black holes have the highest
entropy that you can fit into a region
of fixed size they are in some sense
local maxima of entropy and what that
means is uh operationally that they're
all gonna look alike that's a feature of
high entropy states is that they're not
that interesting
think about um think about black body
radiation think about taking an object
uh a relatively heat proof melting proof
object okay so an object can sustain
some high temperatures but it doesn't
matter what it's made out of it doesn't
matter what color it is it doesn't
matter what shape it is or anything like
that put it in a
tight oven tightly sealed oven uh at a
very fixed temperature and let it come
to equilibrium so let the entire object
inside come to the same temperature the
oven is and then open the oven
what you will see is that the object is
glowing
giving off radiation and the radiation
it gives off and the way it gives it off
is completely independent of the
material it's made out of of the color
it is of the shape it is or anything
like that that is because it has come
into equilibrium with the thermal bath
that it is in and it has a fixed
temperature now you know given its shape
etc it's in a maximum entropy state and
that means it's featureless in terms of
the radiation it gives off and black
holes are the same way black holes as
hawking taught us back in the 70s give
off thermal black body radiation another
sign that they are maximum entropy
states so maximum entropy things you
know given their
macroscopic
constraints like the size the the mass
the charge the spin etc
the whatever quantum states are inside
the black hole
are as
uniform and high entropy as they can
possibly be that is why black holes are
bald now that's a very different
explanation than you would have gotten
back in the late 60s early 70s when they
first started talking about this stuff
because they were not thinking about
quantum states or entropy they were just
thinking about classical general
relativity and it's a feature of
classical general relativity that if you
make a black hole it can have bumps and
wiggles but those bumps and wiggles
quickly radiate away that's what happens
for example when two black holes in
spiral like we see at ligo or something
like that all the individual
idiosyncrasies
of the specific state that went into
making the black hole are
radiated away in the form of
gravitational waves and the black hole
settles down very very quickly so that's
just a feature of classical general
relativity but in some sense it makes a
little more sense to us once we
understand the quantum underpinnings of
that and the fact that it's uh evolving
towards a maximum entropy state in fact
this was the inspiration right there was
a
noticeable set of similarities between
black hole mechanics and thermodynamics
that's what eventually pushed hawking
and beckenstein to show that there is an
entropy and a radiation coming out of
black holes
preston justice says a couple of months
ago my professor called your poetic
naturalism pop philosophy he is a
philosopher and did not mean this
condescendingly but what is your
response to that i understand that your
books are written for a very wide
audience should target those of us who
are non-physicists but you also give us
the math and make us work and put in the
work for your philosophical inquiries as
well
so how would you distinguish real
philosophy from pop philosophy i also
follow the work of david wallace and
love your podcast with him and know you
have been associated with him for some
time i assume you have him and many
other philosophers to consult with
whenever needed right
so i almost didn't answer this question
because you know i don't want to feel
like i'm just defending myself or
something like that but i think this
this touches on a much bigger and really
important issue so i will sort of try to
address it directly specifically and
then go on to the general uh thought
here um look i don't care if someone
calls poetic naturalism pop philosophy
the book the big picture in which i
wrote about poetic naturalism is a
popular level book no question about
that it is not a technical philosophical
tone it is not written in the style that
you would find professional
philosophical writings appearing in
professional philosophy will be much
more
careful about not just uh name checking
all the great minds and other people
who've thought about these issues uh
which i did a little bit but nowhere
near comprehensively it would also be
much more careful typically professional
philosophy especially in these days
tries its best to go through every
single possible permutation of the
argument in front of you in fact this
can be frustrating sometimes as a
scientist who likes philosophy
sometimes philosophers seem to be
content with just listing every possible
answer to a question rather than telling
you what is the right answer
as a scientifically oriented guy
uh i just want to get the right answer
and so that's the spirit both both as
someone who just wants the right answer
and someone who is writing a book for a
popular audience that's the the style in
which all that was talked about in the
big picture now what i do care about is
whether it's right or wrong
right if uh the
the the characterization of it as pop
philosophy was in some sense meant to
imply that it was not serious that it
was wrong somehow then i would like to
know why it's wrong then just labeling a
pop philosophy is kind of meaningless
that is just then you know what carl
bergstrom in the uh podcast episode we
did here
labeled um uh [ __ ] gatekeeping
you know making sure that the
interlopers from outside your discipline
don't come in
but you know i did talk to plenty of
philosophers while writing the book
i've gotten very good responses from
philosophers since then some
philosophers have used the book as texts
in their class
others have disagreed with the book
which is fine that's what i care about i
care about either people agreeing with
it or disagreeing with it less than
whether it's called pop or sirius
but the bigger picture question
which this touches on is you know
there's sort of two dimensions along
which you know we're plotting our
discourse here one is the disciplinary
dimension there's science there's
philosophy there's history there's etc
etc and the other dimension is the sort
of academic versus popular dimension
right and so when i'm writing about
philosophy i'm both being
interdisciplinary you know crossing over
a disciplinary boundary within academia
but also writing for a wide audience not
writing a sort of technical thing and so
the big question is
where do we place our trust you know
forget about me forget about my book but
when we're reading some book or
listening to some source maybe it's a
youtube video or a podcast or an article
in the new york times but it's by some
person and we're not
individually experts in the area that
they are writing about how do we judge
how seriously to take them that's a
really hard question like we would like
to find some simple algorithm for
thinking about it but there is no such
simple algorithm we have to really kind
of think carefully in each individual
case
um now certainly you would like to say
that if someone is a credentialed expert
in a certain field and that's the field
they're writing about then you take them
a little bit more seriously you don't
take them just at face value you don't
say well they must be right because
they're an expert because experts
disagree with each other sometimes but
you put more weight on someone who is
writing about exactly their field but
you also know that even
people who are experts sometimes say
silly things even within their own field
i know physicists who say silly things
about quantum mechanics all the time
some physicists would say i say silly
things about quantum mechanics all the
time so you can't use that as a
completely reliable guide
i am a huge believer
that people in academia should write for
both wider audiences and for other
academic audiences in different fields
while keeping in mind that the process
of doing that is necessarily going to
open you up to making mistakes and being
criticized right um
so i i think that
there's there's some kind of attitude
that says that if you're an expert in
field x you just should not talk about
any other field other than x and i think
that's a terrible attitude how in the
world are we going to make progress if
different fields can't talk about and to
each other but
i would take a philosopher talking about
physics less seriously than a
philosopher talking about philosophy and
vice versa for physicists talking about
philosophy so i think you need to really
take you know attempts for people to
talk outside their credentialed area of
expertise with a grain of salt but there
are techniques we can use to decide who
is trustworthy and who is not and these
techniques have more to do with the
person talking than the thing they're
talking about like once you know that
they're not exactly in their expertise
you shouldn't completely dismiss them
but you should ask questions about how
credible they seem so i mean what does
that mean well you can ask do they seem
to be familiar with the field they're
talking about even if it's not their
technical area of expertise
when they're talking do they seem to be
overly sure of themselves are they very
clear about what is known and what is
not known are they clear about what
they're trying to say with confidence
versus speculating about are they
willing to be wrong are they
falliblistic or are they just sort of
bombastic
are they clearly trying to be
sensationalist
or
contrarian just for the sake of being
contrarian just to sell books or get
clicks or something like that versus are
they trying to work through difficult
issues in good faith to the best they
can right so all of these are things
that you can think about and and try to
take seriously at the end of the day you
have to judge it whether someone is you
know next if you're an expert in
philosophy or physics or anything else
when you read my book or anyone else's
book
you've got to judge how seriously you
want to take that at the end of the day
that's what matters you know whether or
not the ideas are worth something not
whether or not they're popular versus
academic philosophy versus physics or
anything else
regular epistemist says can you give a
very simple explanation about the
difference between primordial
gravitational waves versus gravitational
waves from
inflation um i mean the zeroth order
explanation is no there is no difference
so there's not that much to say but
there is a tiny difference depending on
how exactly you want to get into it
namely gravitational waves from
inflation are a subset of all possible
primordial gravitational waves so
inflation is this idea that in the
super-duper early universe the
primordial universe the universe
underwent a phase of exponential
super-fast expansion
and due to quantum fluctuations that
would naturally generate some
gravitational waves that could leave an
imprint on the universe
cosmologists have not found evidence for
such an imprint yet there was a moment a
couple years ago when we thought maybe
we had but that went away turned out not
to be right
um so inflation predicts that there
should be gravitational waves but it's
silent on exactly how strong they should
be so it's very possible that inflation
is is correct and yet we don't ever find
the gravitational waves predicted by
inflation it is also possible that we do
find them and that would be evidence for
inflation it is also possible that we
find gravitational waves and yet they
come from something other than inflation
and that's tricky because you know if
you don't know what the specific model
is you don't know whether it predicts
gravitational waves or not so i in other
words i can imagine
primordial gravitational waves that are
not from inflation i just don't have any
specifically good uh scenario to to make
them i know there are all sorts of
bouncing and cyclic scenarios and things
like that i find these generally utterly
unconvincing for completely other
reasons so i don't even know personally
you know what which of them would
predict primordial gravitational waves
and which would not
okay i'm going to group some questions
together here
uh three of them perry romanowski says
how do black holes interact with dark
matter does it fall in are there dark
matter black holes adam berger says
since dark matter has mass and therefore
grab generates gravitational force can
it form heavenly bodies can it form
black holes and do we have a short
shield radius for that scenario
and chris chatard says in the lambda cdm
model could it be that dark matter black
holes can form so i don't know why
there were uh simultaneously a bunch of
questions about dark matter black holes
maybe there was a news article or
something or a tweet that i that i
missed out there but you know the short
answer is yes
sure dark matter can make black holes
but in the real world it's much much
much less efficient than ordinary matter
the point is that that ordinary matter
is not dark
it couples to electromagnetic radiation
and dark matter is dark it does not
couple to electromagnetic radiation and
what that means is that when dark matter
particles come close by they just go
right through each other they do not
dissipate you know when atoms bump into
each other they can lose energy
by bumping into each other temporarily
getting excited and then kicking off a
photon right by radiating and radiating
that energy away they lose energy so
when a bunch of atoms or you know
individual ions or electrons or whatever
come near to each other
they can stick together
they can clump they can coalesce
and
black holes are very very very dense to
make a black hole you have to put a lot
of mass a lot of energy into a very very
small region of space even though
there's more dark matter in the universe
than ordinary matter it's not condensed
it is thinly spread throughout the
universe and it has no forces acting on
it that want to
condense it i mean there's gravity but
the problem is you have two dark matter
particles they pull each other through
their mutual gravitational pull and they
come right by and they go right past
each other because they don't stick
because it's only gravity and
gravitational waves are far far too weak
to make that happen
so in principle you can make black holes
out of dark matter in practice it
doesn't really happen now there is a
loophole there it is possible in the
early universe
ordinary matter and dark matter coalesce
in the same place
right so the dark matter might be a
little over dense in a region where the
ordinary matter also is and they both
condense together and even though the
dark matter just goes right through and
the ordinary matter can stick if the
ordinary matter is going along with the
dark matter and it gets so dense that it
makes a black hole that will trap some
of the dark matter in the black hole so
dark matter can contribute to the
formation of black holes in the early
universe and there's some theories that
that's actually important
astrophysically but by itself it'll be
very hard you know if if ordinary matter
we're not helping it along it'll be very
very hard to make uh a dark matter black
hole not impossible but not easy either
relatedly here's another question from
marion markali
is the dark matter transparency a matter
of scale energy or magnitude mismatch in
our tools
similar to the circle and point metaphor
if we only use a point as a probe we can
never find the circle uh this is an
interesting question so um i think i get
it i think i get what you're asking let
me try to rephrase it um you know we say
the dark matter is dark and the easy way
for that to happen is the dark matter
doesn't interact with photons at all
with electromagnetism at all it's
neutral right it's therefore dark
but you but the i think the question
being asked here is can we imagine that
for some reason
dark matter is transparent to certain
wavelengths of light but not to other
wavelengths of light um i think that the
short answer is that in easy models of
dark matter that you would write down
that's hard to make work
because basically think about it this
way you know in in particle physics
a particle is either electrically
charged or it's not
now um in the real world we can make
uh
condensed collections of particles that
are either transparent or opaque right
we can make a piece of wood or a piece
of glass and one of them will
stop light from going through it and the
other one will not
um but the individual particles if they
if you just disperse them all these
particles are charged and they will
interact with photons very very readily
and if they're not interacting with
photons if they're not charged particles
it's hard to make them stick together
like we just said and form substances
okay
so the reason why ordinary matter can
either be transparent or not to
different wavelengths of light is
because of the sort of chemistry and
condensed matter physics of it when they
come together to make different
arrangements of atoms and molecules
not because of the properties of the
individual particles themselves and we
don't think the dark matter does come
together in that way so we think that
the dark matter particles are either
charged or they're not
if they're charged they would not be
dark they'd be visible you could see
them and if they're not charged then uh
they're gonna be dark no matter what you
want so i don't see any simple way um to
make dark matter particles
interact with certain wavelengths of
light but not with other ones there
might be something more clever that i'm
not thinking of right now like maybe the
dark matter particles are not charged
but they have like an electric dipole
moment or something like that um i don't
know that would be a more complicated
model that i would have to think about
parenthetically i cannot help but
mention that there is the possibility of
dark radiation so not only dark matter
but dark photons dark light right this
is an idea that uh i i wrote about with
uh some students well one student lottie
ackerman uh and one postdoc matt buckley
who's now a professor at rutgers and uh
my colleague at the time at caltech mark
kaminkowski who's now at johns hopkins
we wrote a paper
uh what if there was an entirely
different copy of electromagnetism that
only coupled to dark matter not to
ordinary manner and you know
interestingly it can work it's possible
so but still that would not affect how
dark matter interacted with ordinary
matter there or with ordinary uh visible
radiation sorry about that
linear missile says how can an electron
have zero size if it has mass
you know so the first answer i want to
give is why not
who says that you need to have size to
have mass like you're clearly kind of
visualizing some very classical kind of
lump of clay kind of model for the
electrons but you know elementary
particles are not like that
the better answer is
uh electrons don't have zero size i know
people say that they do but electrons
are wave functions and now i'm just
going to assume that my version of
quantum mechanics is the correct one my
many worlds version of quantum mechanics
if you think that the wave function
is really what is going on in the world
whether it's in many worlds or any other
version of quantum mechanics
then electrons don't have zero size you
cannot localize the electron wave
function to a point okay
you can get
an approximate theory of how electrons
behave by starting with the classical
theory of a point particle and
quantizing it
that's the reason why physicists will
sometimes claim that electrons have zero
size but that's just because they're not
taking quantum mechanics seriously right
i mean the quantum theory doesn't have
any memory that you made it from the
classical theory of a point particle
it is in some sense as if when you
measure the electron it is it has no
spatial extent right you can measure it
with an arbitrary precision its position
or something like that but that's a
feature of the measurement process of
quantum mechanics not an intrinsic
feature of the electron itself so real
world electrons do not have zero size
therefore it shouldn't bother you that
they have mass
pete harlan says what are your options
for typesetting equations in the
upcoming biggest ideas in the universe
book despite donald knuth equations in
kindle books seem to fall into two camps
static graphics that don't scale and
look terrible in dark mode or inline
text formatting as in suskin's the
theoretical minimum books that is
unreadable is there an option for an
author that properly accommodates
electronic books
uh so the only reason i have no idea
what the answer to these questions is
they're good questions the reason why
i'm reading it out loud is because i had
never even thought about this but you're
right of course so
you know implicitly in the question
you're asking about the electronic
editions of books
believe me it's hard enough to get the
paper editions published you know the
a publisher like my publisher dutton who
has done um all of my books so far all
my trade books so far
and every one of my trade books has like
one or two equations in it right so they
know how to type set an equation
but this book has a lot of equations in
it uh the biggest ideas in the universe
books coming up and
it's
going to be a little bit tricky to make
sure that everything is italicized
correctly formatted correctly numbered
correctly all of that stuff and i was
already fretting just about getting the
paper edition done correctly and you're
pointing out correctly
that we're going to have to think again
about the electronic edition so
i don't know what the answer is i do
know that my publisher um
is
tries really hard you know they're
they're they don't brush off these
concerns so they will try and now that
you've put the idea into my head i will
at least make sure they're warned ahead
of time about that
question
all right bjorn engstrom says if jeff
bezos were to give you all his money say
250 billion dollars
what would you spend it on and you can't
keep any money for yourself what project
or causes would you fund
i'm very sad i don't get to keep at
least one billion dollars out of 250
billion i mean you know it seems like
you're giving me a lot of work to do and
i get no recompense for it at all but
you know i i don't have a simple answer
to this kind of question i think when
you're talking about that scale of
question so here's how i interpret the
question
how to be a good global citizen if in
the case where you have a huge amount of
money okay so not just like what is the
one single thing you would do i think
there's more than one thing worth doing
with all that money and therefore
you need to sort of set up a system for
diving out different amounts of money to
different kinds of causes and i also
think that you know
it's still worth giving money to some
causes even if they're not the single
highest priority cause that you can
think of like things like solving global
global poverty
or uh educating people worldwide or just
building roads and infrastructure around
the world like these are the most
obvious things to do healthcare
uh for people around the world like
these are things that i probably
couldn't get done for 250 billion
dollars but you could make a dent in it
i think that's well worth doing
but then you know what about like
supporting graduate students in
theoretical physics
or you know supporting local libraries
or uh you know blood drives or things
like that those are also worth doing
even if they might not have a sort of
saving lives per dollar kind of aspect
what about supporting arts organizations
or other good charitable things i think
that all these things are worth doing to
some extent so i would want to you know
have a foundation or something like that
try to have a lean and mean foundation
that did not soak up a lot of the money
itself you know less than one percent of
the total but with you know uh only a
hundredth of a percent of 250 billion
dollars you can still fund a pretty good
foundation
um and
uh or you know maybe i don't know put it
in the bank and live off the interest
not live off the interest but give money
uh off the interest and like i said i
would want to sort of dole it out to
many different things at once starting
with the most high impact things in
terms of saving lives and making the
lives of poor people around the world
better but also putting setting aside
some for
other aspects of life uh cultural
scientific educational aspects and so on
geek god says the scientific method
consists of going back to the drawing
board with your theory if the data
doesn't support it not to just postulate
the existence of supporting data how
does it then make sense to say that dark
matter and dark energy exist just
because we don't see the amount of
matter we expect to see as per the
theory shouldn't we say instead that the
theory is wrong
well
what theory are we talking about here
i mean is the theory
general relativity you know general
relativity doesn't make a prediction all
by itself
for what the rotation curve of a galaxy
should look like it depends on how much
mass is in the galaxy so the theory is
the combination of the theory of gravity
plus the theory of what is causing the
gravity the mass the energy so forth and
when we say there's dark matter and dark
energy
it is precisely that the theory is wrong
that is what we're saying we said we had
a theory namely that the matter that you
see is everything there is
um plus general relativity is the right
theory of gravity we made a prediction
it came out wrong and therefore that
theory is wrong
but adding more matter dark matter or
dark energy or whatever is just as much
changing the theory as changing the
theory of gravity and of course
cosmologists have tried to change the
theory of gravity i've tried to do it it
just doesn't work it doesn't fit the
data so we're very interested in fitting
the data and dark matter and dark energy
fit the data really really well that's
why they're the popular way to go in
these particular
situations
so michael asks a priority question
remember the priority questions uh you
have the rule
that i made up which says that every
person gets to ask a priority question
once in their lives
and i will always try to answer the
priority question so i can't guarantee
i'm not i answer roughly these days half
of the total questions that are at that
are asked i answer half the total
questions that are asked but if you ask
a priority question if you get that one
try i will do my best to answer it
sadly there's no follow-up priority
questions so if i don't answer it in a
way that makes you happy sorry about
that i can't really tell you what to do
anyway so michael's question is
how fast are we moving hurtling through
space if we are still say sitting in a
chair
if we are still aren't we moving at the
speed of the earth's rotation while the
same time the earth is also traveling at
a certain speed hurtling through space
which is traveling through space which
is expanding at a certain speed and so
forth
if one were he's so michael is
anticipating the answer here if one were
to say something like how fast are we
moving relative to what i would then
wonder what is the speed of the
expansion of the universe relative to
so the correct answer to the first part
of the question is
relative to what i mean that's how
that's what relativity says there's no
such thing as the speed with which
you're traveling there just is no such
thing you really have to accept that
it's not just like a fun little motto
uh there's only the relative speed
between different objects and so there's
no such thing as the speed that you're
moving at when you're sitting on a chair
you always have to say relative to what
then you say what is the speed of the
expansion of the universe relative to
but the answer there is that the
expansion of the universe does not have
a speed
it just doesn't it has a rate
you can ask in a certain period of time
by what percentage will the scale factor
of the universe expand but that is not a
quantity that is measured in meters per
second it does not even have the units
of speed it has units of one over time
and that time is roughly speaking the
time scale for universe to double in
size
uh so that's not a velocity that is
relative to something else that is a
rate of increase in some quantity which
can be perfectly well defined so it's a
different kind of thing than the
velocity with which you're traveling
through space
jeremy dittman says i'm wondering about
your views on the future of scientific
progress say a hundred to a thousand
years from now and whether or not major
advances on big problems quantum gravity
rules of complexity emergence etc would
ultimately be taught to the equivalent
of high school students in the future
that's a good question um you know you
can certainly imagine what people would
have said if you asked this question 500
years ago and they're like yeah you know
you might come up with crazy new
theories but they won't ever trickle
down to high school students but these
days we do indeed teach high school
students uh natural selection or
newton's
laws of motion
you know we don't
teach them maxwell's equation we don't
even treat them teach them
boltzmann's equation for
entropy or anything like that so there's
plenty of things over 100 years ago that
we do not teach them
and so the short answer is i don't know
um i can see it either way i i would
imagine that some things that we learn
over the next hundred or thousand years
will
turn out to be both so fundamental
and so readily understandable that it is
completely possible to teach them
to high school students and we will end
up doing that i can also imagine that
the things we learn just remain a little
bit too esoteric in the sense that to
really understand them
you would need to have a lot of
background you need to do a lot of
prerequisite work to learn
how to manipulate equations or some
abstract mathematical concepts or
something like that so i think it'll be
a mixture of those things um
it's hard to be more definite than that
because i don't know what the scientific
advances are going to be right
i mean i don't really think that
high school students are going to be
doing
a lot of you know tensor analysis or
something like that like you need for
general relativity they could in
principle i could imagine but you know
it takes a lot of work to learn the
background concepts to get up to that
point so i don't think it's simply a
matter of as time passes we compress
these ideas into earlier and earlier
educational stages um
but
there might be some brand new ideas
about emergence or about space time or
whatever that are actually simple enough
to teach the high school students i i
just don't know
chris mortlock says
is the process of acquiring knowledge
limitless or limited do you think it's
possible a civilization could ever
acquire total knowledge with no further
branches of scientific discovery
possible
uh no i don't think that's possible you
know i think that it is possible to know
the laws of physics
uh you know i've said many times that we
know the laws of physics that are
relevant to our everyday lives but that
we don't know the laws of physics
outside our everyday lives we don't
understand quantum gravity or dark
matter or what happened to the big bang
etc i think it's possible that we could
know them however so i certainly imagine
that someday we might either
know all the fundamental laws of physics
or at least
have a theory that purports to be the
fundamental laws of physics that is both
completely consistent and fits all the
data you always want to keep open the
possibility you're gonna have to revise
your ideas later on down the line right
so even if it is the correct theory
you're not sure
um but here's why i don't think you'll
ever know all the laws of science uh
broadly construed is because you can
always just get more detailed right
you know a human being
cannot
carry in their brains enough information
to completely describe another human
being
because by a complete description you
would mean the position and the momentum
of every single atom in that other human
being and there's just not enough room
in your brain to hold all that
information right uh so we that's why we
coarse grain and do higher order
approximations and things like that so
we might have theories of psychology and
sociology etc that are really really
really good
but still are based on incomplete
information and so i think there will
always be more we can learn because
there's just you know until
we are ourselves as big as the universe
uh there is an obstacle in principle for
us to understand everything that is
happening in the universe right and
that's why none of us is or ever will be
laplace's demon
kundal menda says
kudo i'm sorry kunal menda says
do you tell your guests what you intend
to ask them before a podcast how much
have they typically prepared their
answers
um very little you know look most people
who i talk to they have a spiel right
they have something they like to talk
about that is kind of pretty obvious uh
so we don't need to do a lot of
negotiations sometimes there are people
who you know have certainly done a lot
like when you talk to dan dennett uh
he's done a lot of different things you
talked to roger penrose he's done a lot
of different things and so
you might want to say well okay let's
pick this to focus in on um and i do
generally say that ahead of time in the
invite letter but i also offer them the
opportunity to say actually what we
should talk about is this other thing
um but that's it it's really just a
couple of sentences back and forth it's
certainly not the case that i
tell them the questions i'm going to ask
since i don't know those often times
before we even start the interview like
i have a
kind of bullet point outline at best and
then try to work from that but you want
the interview to be not overly planned i
think that in my very early days
of podcasting i i planned too much you
know like i really had my questions plot
out ahead of time which is no good way
to do it you know you want some points
you want to hit but the specific
questions and the specific uh give and
take has to come organically out of the
interview and you know again most of the
people
who i have it's not their first rodeo
they've done this before
so they're pretty good at
offering answers that sort of make sense
i do try to have you know as i said
before i like diversity along many axes
and one axis is
youth to age and seniority right so i
have some famous uh senior people and i
have some younger people relatively just
starting out and unsurprisingly young
people just starting out are less
practiced at you know hitting the sweet
spot of long enough answers
to you know give some meaty details
without just giving a little mini
lecture every time right
so that's a skill you develop over time
that's okay i'm happy to play a tiny
role in uh exposing certain young
promising people to a wider audience and
giving them a chance to sort of hone
their technique at uh addressing these
questions in real time like that
frank layman says
do you think twitter is a net good or
negative for physics and science more
broadly it seems that for every positive
interaction one has on the social
network there are ten others that
confirm its reputation as being a hell
site
um you know look i i don't know whether
it's a good net good for physics or
science like that's very hard to tell
you know
most physicists and scientists don't use
twitter
i think that you can get a very
distorted view of the world by taking
twitter too seriously as reflecting what
is going on in the wider world okay and
that's just as true for it's even more
true for physics than it is for
something like politics or sports or
whatever um
and physicists are the worst like
physicists don't
don't use social media at all compared
to other things and there's a broader
point here um that you know i've said
before but it's worth
emphasizing that um both the people
who come to mind when you say a
physicist in the modern world and the
issues that come to mind when you say
like what art physicists care about in
the modern world
are completely different in the public
sphere and in the academic sphere
there's some overlap but it's
kind of small this overlap so you know
the things that get talked about in
physics departments among physicists
uh there's a certain set of issues a
certain set of people who are looked up
to as you know wise voices that we
should pay attention to etc certain set
of questions that we care about and
they're not utterly unrelated to what we
talk about on twitter and elsewhere in
public but they're very different
and so i kind of sometimes have to roll
my eyes uh you know when people give
their lists of the top five physicists
alive today i mean look if i appear on
that list then you know the person is
not credible
i'm a good physicist but not anyone's
idea of one of the top five physicists
alive today but people you know very
naturally
attribute
slightly more importance to their
favorite public figures than they would
do to professors who they've never heard
of
anyway
the point about is twitter good for for
physics or for science you know
one thing about twitter is it's optional
they have not yet made it compulsory
they've not yet made it mandatory if you
yourself find twitter
to be um
dragging you down then just don't do it
that would be my advice
like i use twitter and i like it and i
i'm not i'm not trying to um
make light of the fact that twitter can
be a downer because
there's a lot of people on there who
with the best of intentions i mean some
obviously have bad intentions but forget
about those people but even with the
best of intentions there are people who
use social media to highlight problems
in the world
um to you know point out injustices or
mistakes or falsehoods or misinformation
and if you're just being reminded of
that aspect of the world all the time
even if you know all the people you're
listening to or ones you agree with it
drags you down it just it just weighs on
you
you need to have some joy in there my
own tweeting i like to try to you know
mix in
me railing against the injustices of the
universe with you know more fun uh
uplifting enlightening things as well
and
you get to pick who you follow on
twitter right so if if you're constantly
being bombarded with things that bring
you down
then you have to ask why you're
following the people who are doing that
to you and if if you just can't avoid it
then you have to ask why you're on there
at all i think it's obvious that twitter
is a wonderful source for broadcasting
information like some people like to
have conversations on twitter they like
to go back and forth and discuss things
and i just have no interest in doing
that and i don't mean to insult anybody
but when i tweet something and someone
responds to it the chances that i will
respond to their response are almost
zero because i just don't think it's
useful for that it's a broadcasting
medium if i want to learn about you know
what is
when when the ligo experiment found
evidence for gravitational waves that
news spread on twitter faster than
anywhere else right that is the kind of
thing twitter is super duper useful for
linking to things that are longer more
careful things but not for having
in-depth conversations about things so i
find twitter very very useful and
helpful for that but different people's
mileage will vary
paul torek says in ever ready in quantum
mechanics individual branches get
thinner over time their amplitudes get
smaller so they make smaller and smaller
contributions to the total energy of the
universe suppose we fashion half the
mass of the solar system into spaceships
and toss a quantum coin heads we send
out the fleet tails we set day a few
more decades to improve the ships we
observe tails do we
expect the local curvature of space time
to be reduced as our other branch
siblings fly away resulting in a lower
all branches local mass energy density
so in other words
in case that thought case i edited a
little bit so it's not entirely paul's
fault here but in case that wasn't clear
imagine we do a quantum experiment where
there's two different possible outcomes
and in one outcome we send off a lot of
mass and the other one we don't would we
feel a different gravitational field no
we do not otherwise the i mean to say
that we would is to say that the
existence of this other branch of the
wave function of the universe would be
observable i mean that would be great
that would be wonderful but within each
branch the laws of physics of ordinary
classical physics are more or less
obeyed so the matter that is in the
branch
you know when you when you
say the earth i mean just do a simpler
version of your thought experiment say
that there is a spin you're measuring 50
50 chance to be spin up or spin down and
you have a bomb that destroys the earth
with 50 50 probability right
um
and you live you find yourself you do
the experiment and you find yourself on
the branch where the earth is not
destroyed does the earth suddenly get uh
half of its mass disappearing no that is
not what happens because the mass exists
within each branch and the branching
does not change the amount of mass in a
single branch at all
modulo a little tiny effect which is
what i wrote about my recent paper with
jackie lodman that of course
if the two branches the two branches can
be slightly different in energy as long
as their average is the same as the
energy that you had before um but
there's a difference and this is just
why it's it's this is what the math is
again completely crystal clear about
this completely unambiguous there's a
difference between the energy you
perceive from within a branch of the
universe and the contribution of that
branch to the energy of the whole wave
function of the universe the energy you
perceive from within a branch doesn't
change no matter what's happening on the
other branches
richard graff says
i'm reading and enjoying chintzins
sorry i can never pronounce this
person's name i'm sorry mr liu
uh
chin chin liu's three body problem
series
in it a character describes a proton in
a high dimensional space being unfolded
into a lower dimensional space one of
the results is that the object's size
grows immensely large in the lower
dimension and increasingly so as it
unfolds into even lower dimensions
does this unfolding concept and the
describe size increase have any
mathematical or physical validity or is
it just a clever literary device um
i don't know is the short answer you
know whenever you have something like
a physics process
translated into a science fiction novel
two things are happening one is the
novelist will
ignore the laws of physics in favor of
telling the story they want to tell but
also number two
even if they're obeying the laws of
physics they're not writing down the
equations they're using metaphorical
descriptions to try to give you a
feeling for what is happening so
no nothing in those words
corresponds cleanly and crisply to
anything that i know about that could
actually happen in the real world
um the closest is the idea of living on
a brain
b-r-a-n-e
uh which is sort of a sub-space
of a larger higher dimensional space so
we see a three-dimensional world around
us it is possible that that
three-dimensional world is a
three-dimensional brain
uh back construction from the word
membrane so a three-brain embedded in a
four-dimensional space or
five-dimensional space or something like
that um and there are particles the
reason why we don't mention why we don't
notice the extra dimensions is because
the particles of which we are made are
stuck to the brain okay
now as far as i know
there's no sensible theory in which
something like an electron or a proton
can be stuck to a brain and then escape
and then you know fly off into the extra
dimensions particles and fields either
are or are not stuck to the brains um
but you know maybe you could i mean what
what you can imagine happening is two
particles annihilating two particles
that are stuck to the brain can
annihilate and change into particles
that are not stuck to the brain and that
just appears to us on the brain as
missing energy energy would disappear
from our observable universe
only the observable universe not the
real universe has nothing to do with
quantum mechanics here um but that is a
possible thing so i think that's the
closest thing that i can think of that
is an analogy to uh that particular
example in the novel
paul hess says can you explain the
relationship if any between entropy and
weak emergence i began to think about
this when anil seth described weak
emergence as higher level behavior that
cannot be predicted from the lower level
components without exhaustive simulation
an exhaustive simulation sounds to me
like it represents information that is
not compressible and in computer science
they use the idea of entropy to talk
about how compressible something is does
it
make any sense for me to think of
entropy and emergence as related
concepts
um yes i think that they are related and
in fact i would go so far as to say that
we're not sure or at least i'm not sure
i've done a little bit of work on this
um i don't think we can completely
articulate right now what the
relationship is because frankly i think
that our despite the fact that we babble
about it all the time
i think that our understanding of how
immersions works is pretty primitive and
uh not very general you know we've
looked at it in certain
cases but you know the general theory of
when and how
one description emerges from another one
is
very primitive i think very
underdeveloped so here is the sense in
which uh entropy does
well
there is a sense potentially which
entropy is related to emergence um and
there's a trivial sense in which that's
true namely the following what if
we were in equilibrium
what if we were in the highest entropy
state it is possible to be in then there
would be no emergence the entropy would
not be increasing
but also we'd be in equilibrium
everything would be you know whatever
configuration it would be in presumably
smooth and featureless and so there'd be
no stuff to be higher level
objects in the emergent theory right
in the real world um emerging things
like human beings or whatever are
constantly increasing the entropy of the
universe now that's not
perfect or exact what i just said
because
another example of emergence is you know
the earth moving around the sun
the earth can be described by its center
of mass coordinates
and
it doesn't need to be increasing in
entropy for that to happen it's true
that the configuration of the earth plus
the sun is very low entropy compared to
thermal equilibrium
but it's not increasing in entropy in
any noticeable way that increase in
entropy is not playing an important role
in the emergence of the earth as just a
point mass going around the sun
so that's why it's complicated that's
why it's hard so i do think there is a
relationship um
one more fact about that so you don't
have the general theory i can just throw
out facts and you can make of them what
you will
um
there is a relationship to this word
that you use compression
the whole idea of emergence is that
there are many many
states that you could imagine specifying
in the underlying microscopic theory
that look the same that correspond to
the same state in the macroscopic theory
so for the earth moving around the sun
there's 10 to the 50th particles in the
earth there are many many ways to
arrange them so that the center of mass
position and velocity of the earth is
the same and so that's a compression
right the whole idea of
emergence absolutely takes advantage of
the compressibility of the microscopic
theory in some way and whenever you
compress there's an associated entropy
you can you can ask about how many ways
are there to arrange the microscopic
constituents so as to make the
macroscopic thing and that's the
logarithm of that is going to be an
entropy it's not like necessarily the
thermodynamic entropy etc but it's
related so i think this is all a very
rich vein to imagine mining as we work
towards a better understanding of
emergence going forward
brendan asks how would you apply
bayesian reasoning between a deity and
an advanced alien being
if an entity suddenly appeared and
performed actions that defied our
current understanding of physics how
would you update your bayesian
probability i think many people be quick
and wait heavily for a deity but it
wouldn't be completely unreasonable to
think an alien race millions or billions
of years more advanced to perform things
that we think are not possible
um yeah that's a very good question i
think it would depends on the specifics
right like is the
um well okay
let me be even more fair than that um
i'm not at all sure that the deity
concept is even
uh
coherent
so i would tend to put low prior
probability on the deity idea
number one because it requires violating
or understanding how the universe works
right whereas aliens do not number two i
think that a lot of our
ways of talking about god-like creatures
come from starting with our ways of
talking about ordinary human beings and
exaggerating them
and exaggerating them so much to talk
about them being infinitely bigger or
better or more powerful but i don't
really think that move is very rigorous
or very um easy to make sense of you
know the there's a standard line about
god being omnipotent and omniscient and
omni-benevolent and there's standard
objections that say well you can't be
all of those things because if you were
perfectly good you wouldn't let all this
bad stuff happen in the world and
there's clever theological moves and
maneuvers you can use to get around that
conclusion but the simple conclusion is
the whole idea was just half baked from
the first from the start
so my
um
immediate priors would be mostly on
highly advanced technological
civilization rather than deity but i'm
willing to update them you know let's
talk to these people um
i don't see why an infinitely uh
powerful being would talk to me
or hasn't talked to me yet but would
start you know there's a million ways in
which the concept doesn't quite make
sense to me but you know if they claimed
that uh there was some uh reason that
they could demonstrate that they were uh
more supernatural than natural then i
would give them the chance to do that
and and see what happened
kathy seeger says i've read an article
on wikipedia about dark fluid theory in
which they aim at unifying dark matter
and dark energy the theory proposes that
dark matter and dark energy are strongly
linked together and be can considered
can be considered as two facets of a
single fluid at galactic scales the dark
fluid behaves like dark matter and at
larger scales its behavior becomes
similar to dark energy what do you think
of it um so i don't know exactly what is
being referred to here there's sort of
more than one idea that that has been
labeled dark fluid in some sense it's a
natural kind of thing look i already
talked about dark radiation and dark
photons like once you invent dark matter
and dark energy you're gonna start
inventing a lot of different dark stuff
just to see uh how much you can get away
with um
i certainly think that
any of these
sort of more elaborate baroque theories
are should be given much lower credence
than the simple theory because we have a
very simple theory for dark matter and
dark energy dark energy is a
cosmological constant
and dark matter is some cold weakly
interacting or non-interacting massive
particle
those are two very very simple ideas
that fit all the data you know up to
your usual collection of tiny anomalies
like we talked about with priya
natarajan before there's a tiny anomaly
there in the gravitational lensing
there's other anomalies here and there
but with astrophysical anomalies you
know there's a lot of phenomena that
you're observing occasionally you'll
find an anomaly and occasionally it will
go away so
there's no super strong killer evidence
against that very very simple theory so
it's worth trying to invent better
theories because you know there's
there's absolutely
open questions about the simple theory
um but until there's really a very well
motivated and empirically successful
version of them
i would not put too much credence in
them
i know that justin cory at the
university of pennsylvania has a very
interesting theory about
something some super fluid dark matter i
don't think he's trying to explain away
dark energy in the acceleration of the
universe but he's trying to explain
the behavior of dark matter in galaxies
and clusters and he says he can do that
in a very specific way i think that kind
of thing is promising the particle
physics behind it is a little
clunky and unnatural
but if you can really explain something
astrophysically maybe it's worth it it's
certainly worth at least thinking about
it you know i'm in favor of work going
forward in these directions
sam hartzog says
do mathematical functions like integrals
differential equations etc have some
kind of metric tied to them to represent
something like how many independent bits
of information are required to carry out
meaningful operations it occurred to me
that a notation like tensor calculus
allows you to write things pretty
concisely and wonder if there's any kind
of metric for hidden computational
complexity uh so i debated whether to
answer this question or not because it
kind of violates my rules it's a good
question but i don't have anything
interesting to say about it i mean the
short answer is as no as far as i know
there's not a kind of metric
um
a metric on this space of
operations you need to do
to
perform a certain operation to transform
a certain function or some something
like that there are certain very
um restricted domains in which you can
do something like that and that's that's
what made me think of it so in
particular
let's say you're doing quantum mechanics
and let's say that you're doing quantum
mechanics in a finite dimensional
setting so not finite dimensions of
space but finite dimensions of hilbert
space of the quantum mechanical um
space of possibilities so in particular
let's be even more specific let's
imagine you have qubits let's imagine
you're doing something like a quantum
computer okay
so you have a bunch of qubits and you're
going to act on them and it's it's very
much like a regular computer you act on
bits in a regular computer using gates
right and gates not gates
xor whatever you know if you've studied
computer science you know there's a set
of things you can do with two bits to
turn them into one bit or another two
bits or et
similarly with uh quantum information
and qubits and so if you have a set of
qubits and you have a set of allowed
gates
right so you have gates that can act on
these two qubits one at a time and so
you can't just act really nilly on any
two qubits but there's a set of cubists
like maybe the qubits are arranged in a
line or they're arranged in a lattice on
a two-dimensional plane or something
like that and you allow gates to
interact on nearest neighbors okay
then
you can talk about the complexity of the
resulting quantum state or the amount of
entanglement in the resulting quantum
state so you start with a quantum state
that is completely unentangled and you
act on it
pairs of qubits at a time with your
allowed gates okay
and then there's a simple metric on how
complicated your quantum state is namely
what is the smallest number of allowed
gates that will get you to the state you
want to get to from some given starting
point
as you might gather from that from that
um uh explanation
it's a very very specific situation
you're looking at there it's very far
away from a general theory of
transforming one function into another
or one vector into another anything like
that so i think that's the state of the
art as far as i know um
because if you don't make those
restrictions let's say you just start
with one quantum state and and go to
another quantum state and you say
without restricting on you know the set
of gates i can use and whatever
in principle how many steps does it take
me to get from one quantum state to the
other and the answer is always one
one step
if you really cleverly pick your
operation you can always go from any one
orientation of a vector in some vector
space to any other orientation
whatsoever so i think the general theory
there is going to fall short unless you
make some other choices about what
operations are allowed and then maybe
you can make some progress
ties johnson says
you've convinced me of everetty in
quantum mechanics so much i can't see
any problems with it i listen to the
podcast with david albert twice and read
something deeply hidden twice but i
still can't see the problem with
probabilities and then he goes on to
explain you know what his issue is with
the problem of probability so rather
than reading
your issue with the issue let me just do
my best to say how i interpret david's
objection to many worlds you know the
way that i think about the origin of
probability in many worlds is via
self-locating uncertainty chip siebens
and i wrote a paper about this to try to
formalize it etc based on ideas that
other people used lev weidman voitek
zurek and others and the basic idea is
when you measure a quantum system
or when a quantum system
is measured it doesn't need to be a
person or even an apparatus but when a
tiny quantum system decoheres when it
becomes entangled with its environment
and therefore the wave function of the
universe branches into multiple copies
i know i can predict ahead of time with
certainty that there will be a version
of me on every one of the copies okay
and it happens very rapidly this
splitting of the wave function happens
far more rapidly than any one of those
copies are aware of so after the
splitting there are many copies of me or
just two or whatever some number
and none of them know where they are
that's the self-locating uncertainty so
is there a way for those people
those future versions of me
to assign a credence to being on one
branch of the wave function of the
universe versus another and chip and i
argue that if you you know if you try to
answer that question in some sensible
way there is only one possible
reasonable answer which is the born rule
of quantum mechanics you assign a
probability or a credence to being on
any one branch that is given by the
amplitude of that branch squared and
david albert would like to say no i have
another perfectly reasonable possibility
as he says in the podcast namely
i have no clue
[Laughter]
and that's that's his attitude he says
like i don't i can't you can't force me
to say well what is the most reasonable
probability measure to put on this
because there's
n copies of me
they're all in identical situations how
can they say anything at all about the
probability of being on one branch or
another especially because none of them
can observe that none of them can
observe
the amplitude of the branch that they
are on you can ahead of time predict uh
you know you can set up the initial
quantum state so that you know what the
branch amplitudes will be ahead of time
but once you're on a branch
it's just a it's just a branch you don't
know what the amplitude is sitting
outside it has no effect the amplitude
doesn't change the dynamics of your
branch once you are on it so david just
says the alternative to choosing this
sensible born rule set of credences is
not to choose credences at all just to
say i don't know what branch i'm on and
therefore i cannot predict anything
so i think the mistake there is there's
two well there's two it's not even a
mistake it's an attitude you're allowed
to take it so it's not a mistake you're
allowed to take that attitude um i think
it's not the right or best attitude to
take for two reasons number one is
there is an obvious
probability measure to use it's not like
we're completely clueless like everyone
agrees on what the obviously correct one
is if you think that there is one okay
and that's the bourne rule like as i
often say there was never any
any possibility that would be the wave
function cubed or the logarithm of the
wave function it's always going to be
the wave function squared that's the set
of numbers that add up to one and are
conserved over time okay
but the other is more importantly that
there is sort of a normative reason
for
choosing a set of credences normative in
the sense of it's a judgmental thing
it's not forced on you by the world but
it's something that you want to do if
you know what is going on and it's the
same normative reason that we want to
correctly describe physics at all that
we correctly want to have a theory of
how the world works
when you are going to jump off of a
building
you have a theory of what's going to
happen when you jump off the building
you can't say well maybe i'll fall down
and hurt myself or maybe i'll float off
into the sky
both are possible
right so who knows
i mean they are both possible if you
really strictly go by the meaning of
what possible means it is possible that
this time you will fly up into the sky
rather than go down to the ground
but you don't give it equal credence to
the idea that you'll go down to the
ground because you're trying to
understand the world the best you can
you have some experience with the past
you have some rules for assigning
credences to different possible worlds
that you could live in that's a kind of
self-locating uncertainty you don't know
what the laws of physics are in the
world you're in there's a world a
possible world where the laws of physics
say that gravity is attractive and you
will fall down off the building there is
a possible world where the laws of
physics say the gravity is attractive
right up until the moment you jump and
then gravity becomes repulsive
it's possible right you assign very very
low credence to that world and there's
reasonable reasons to do that they're
not metaphysically certain you could be
wrong but it's the best you can do under
the circumstances that's how i think
about the everettian probabilities
you're there on a branch
you can
just decide not to assign credences at
all i can't stop you it's a free country
but it's not the best way to do the best
job you can do of understanding how the
world works and where you are in the
world and once you accept that then
you're going to put the bourne rule
credences on those branches
okay i'm going to group two questions
together
about zombies
oh many of you know i should have
mentioned this
but in case you didn't know i did a
podcast a long podcast with philip gough
and keith frankish
uh philip of course has been a mindscape
guest before he is a promoter of
pancychism in the theory of
consciousness and keith is a on the
opposite side of the consciousness
debates he's also a philosopher he's a
proponent of illusionism he doesn't
think that qualia
in the strict philosophical sense are
even real they're just illusions um so
we talked about
why i'm a physicalist about these things
and it was a useful conversation we
talked about zombies a lot and then i
wrote a follow-up blog post
uh on the zombie argument for
physicalism if you're interested in that
so this is partly what is um
uh
instigating these questions so one is
from keith i don't think it's keith
frankish it's a person named keith who
says i enjoyed your blog post on p
zombies uh for physicalism and visit on
minechat minechat is the name of the
podcast and p zombies are philosophical
zombies so for those of you don't know
a p zombie is the idea that
we could imagine exactly two different
again two different possible worlds one
of which i have real human beings
and they have all their conscious
experiences and all this stuff the real
world as we think and we know it but i
also according to this thought
experiment could imagine a different
possible world
made of the same kinds of matter right
same kinds of quantum mechanics and
electrons and protons and neutrons etc
obeying exactly the same laws of physics
doing exactly the same things
um but no consciousness
okay
and the people who live in that world i
would call them zombies and so sorry i'm
departing from keith's question here but
i'm giving you background if you don't
already know so the zombie argument
is the idea that because in principle i
can conceive of the same exact physical
collection of matter with and without
consciousness
consciousness much must be something
other than
some way of talking about the physical
behavior of that collection of matter of
course i would say that that's begging
the question because
you can only conceive of those zombies
if
you uh
believe that consciousness is not
physical if you believe that
consciousness is just an emergent thing
to talk about uh describing the
underlying physical behavior of matter
then you cannot conceive of zombies
because the same exact physical
collection of matter exactly behaving in
exactly the same way would be conscious
under that definition okay that is the
argument that goes back and forth so
keith's question is
i followed up the reasoning for most
part but i really get hung up a bit
upstream
as a fellow physicalist i don't really
get how a p zombie is even conceivable
or maybe my notion of conceivability is
too strict and then another question
from graeme clark that says do you think
that a philosophical zombie is actually
conceivable your arguments against
psychism seem to indicate that but i
wonder why the zombie concept hasn't
been rejected um yes so i think you're
both correctly putting your fingers on
something that i didn't make very clear
in my blog post the answer is
zombies are not conceivable that's what
you have to say if you're a physicalist
who thinks that consciousness is just
weakly emergent that's just what i said
if you think that consciousness is just
a way of talking about the collective
behavior and higher level
ways of talking about a collection of
particles doing certain things then
there's there's no way to remove
consciousness from that and therefore
zombies are not conceivable so
i wrote that in the paper that i wrote i
wrote a paper
for the journal of consciousness studies
in the writing a philosophy paper
that was responding to philip goff's
ideas but i didn't make that very clear
in the blog post because i was in a rush
by the time i finished it it was already
too long so yes the punch line is
that uh taking the zombie argument at
face value as it is usually given only
works if you assume ahead of time that
consciousness is not physical otherwise
zombies become not conceivable so that
is the correct way to think about it yes
alejandro gonzalez says let us suppose
we discover that consciousness is a
fundamental property of nature which i
know you're inclined to think is
emergent
what could the implications be of that
for the current understanding of physics
and the model of the universe we have
now just entertain us with some
plausible possibilities if there are any
at all
well this is hard to do because i don't
think it makes sense i don't think it's
true anyway
and part of the reason why i don't think
it's true that consciousness is a pro
fundamental property of nature is that i
haven't seen even the slightest gesture
toward a serious theory of that i mean
you can attach words to the existing
theories of quantum field theory or
whatever and say oh it's all made of
consciousness but i don't see any
operational meaning to how that is
supposed to happen
as i emphasized in the podcast with
philip and keith and in my blog post and
elsewhere
either
you change the dynamics of the particles
and fields we know about or you don't
that is true about anyone's theory of
consciousness you either do that or you
don't okay and if you don't then i just
don't see what it matters there's just
no implications of that idea and if you
do
show me the equations show me exactly
how the equations that we think work
are wrong show me what the additional
parts of them are i mean that's what you
do if you are a physicist inventing a
new theory of gravity or new model of
dark matter or explanation for the
hierarchy problem you show us the
equations and we can work out from them
what the implications of those are and i
don't know what those would be for a
theory of consciousness as a fundamental
property of nature so i truly don't know
i'm not trying to you know be coy about
it or anything like that i'm just not
even sure how that would work i think
that you know there's sort of a
feeling that people have that
consciousness can't be just physical
stuff because of their introspection but
i i don't know whether that feeling
actually leads anywhere sensible in
terms of how the universe works
krather luca says regarding your theory
on the arrow of time in last month's ama
you mentioned something along the lines
of i don't necessarily think my theory
with jennifer chen is true but i think
that there's a non-zero chance that it's
true however i know of no better theory
regarding the arrow of time
if you believe you have the best theory
isn't the rational thing to do than to
regard it as true we can never truly
justify our beliefs so what other reason
can we have for believing something is
true besides it being the current best
theory of some part of reality
um so no i don't think that's exactly
right you know i think that for me to
say it's the best current theory
um
requires that i should give it in in
this case not it's not really a theory
of the arrow of time so much as the
theory of the arrow time is
entropy increases because of boltzmann's
explanation for what entropy was plus
the fact that the entropy near the big
bang was low that's the arrow of time
but then the question is why was the
entropy low near the big bang that's
what i and jennifer uh chen had a theory
of um and i still think it as far as i
know is the best theory that i've heard
of so
i think that what that requires in order
to be self-consistent is i give more
credence to that theory than to any
other theory
however the total number of other
theories might be very large and there
might be a large amount of credence i
give to the some theory in the set of
theories no one has articulated yet
right
um it's a little bit different than to
say something like you know my theory in
many worlds is my credence in many
worlds is 95 or something like that
that's a situation where you know we
have several competing theories we know
what they are we can articulate them
pretty clearly and they're all in some
ways successful and i can judge them
against each other whereas for something
like this we have no
really good theories including my own
because there's a lot of
understood physics that is involved in
our own theories about you know how baby
universes could be created or something
like that how you calculate a measure to
talk about probabilities and make
predictions and all of these things so
there are no great theories
our theory i think is the most promising
one among the not very good theories and
in that situation you should still give
a hefty amount of credence to i just
don't know yet we haven't thought of the
right answer so i would not say that i
believe it's true even if i think it's
the best theory currently out there
tareem shahab says what is energy
in high school they would define they
would always say energy is the ability
to do work and then define works in
terms of energy i've also heard it
described as bookkeeping is that all it
is or is it more meaningful
well it's certainly not the ability to
do work
that's not a good definition because
there are forms of energy that literally
are defined as the kinds of energy that
can't do meaningful work you know the
heat the uh the thermal energy in an
equilibrium system is in its highest
entropy state you can't do useful work
with it uh that's what free energy is
free energy is the energy that is about
is available to do work
non-free energy is the energy locked up
in the equilibrium uh high entropy
configuration
okay so it's not that but what is it you
know
there's different definitions and i
think that the favorite one and probably
the right one even though it doesn't
make a lot of instant intuitive sense is
the quantity that is conserved because
the laws of physics are independent of
time
you know if you think about
and this is easiest to sort of gain
intuition for by thinking of
the converse what if the laws of physics
were not invariant over time right so
you know that would be like
masses of particles or strengths of
forces or something like that just
changing as time goes on and as you
might imagine if i have a particle
moving you know just in a straight line
according to newton's laws but its mass
is changing then if momentum is
conserved
the velocity of the particle would be
changing even though its mass because
its mass is changing whereas if momentum
is not conserved
but velocity is conserved then its
momentum is not conserved over time and
in either case is the energy conserved
over time because basically
intuitively this might not be exactly
correct but intuitively it's kind of
like
something is pumping energy into the
system by changing the mass of the
particle
so
because we live in a world where the
particles have more or less constant
masses the forces are more or less
locked in with their um strengths and so
the overall laws of physics are
basically
constant over time uh there is no extra
thing oomph impetus put into the system
and we call the quantity that is
conserved because of that symmetry
energy now this is a hand wavy way of
saying a much more rigorous result
nerder's theorem i mean erder proved
that whenever you have uh certain kinds
of classical mechanical systems that
have uh uh
symmetry that symmetry is associated
with a conservation law
momentum is associated with the fact
that things are
translationally invariant in space you
can move in either x y or z directions
the laws of physics don't change so you
have three conserved quantities the
three
components of the momentum vector and
you also have translations in time
and the quantity that is conserved with
respect to that is energy
it's not a very intuitive definition i
know that but uh that is what the
mathematical definition is and it
matches up with our intuitive definition
of you know some combination of
potential energy and kinetic energy and
heat and stuff like that
horstvorst says what is your bayesian
prior of finding compelling evidence of
biosignatures in the atmospheres of
exoplanets in the next couple of decades
oh this is a great question because it's
specific enough to make sense
like one should have a bayesian prior
about this but it's really hard to know
what it is
i'm going to
put it low i'm gonna put it at let's say
uh ten percent
and this is the reason why this is
difficult is because of course
um we have a
certain we have two pieces of
information i don't even want to say
data points but two pieces of
information one is life exists here on
earth right we're flourishing here on
earth the other is we haven't seen
already sort of in an in your face kind
of way life elsewhere either elsewhere
on other planets in the solar system or
aliens flying by and saying hi to us
from elsewhere in the milky way so
those are two pieces of information you
have to reconcile with each other the
easiest reconciliation
is that in some sense
life elsewhere is rare
and of course as a selection effect
we're only going to exist where life
exists so the fact that we exist here on
earth is not really telling us that much
but
there are lots of steps along the way
from no life at all
to an intelligent civilization on
another planet and any one of those
could be a bottleneck that uh explains
why we haven't seen other intelligent
civilizations yet so it might be that
there's no life but it also might be
that life is everywhere it's ubiquitous
it's it's very common but it's always
only
multi or single-celled or something like
that not very technologically advanced
that's why it's very hard to make a good
bayesian prior so i'm going to put it at
10
don't ask me to justify that i might
change my mind if we learn more about
chemistry or or geology or something
like that
robert ruxin rescue says a few days ago
elon musk responded to a bernie sanders
tweet about the rich paying their fair
share to society by commenting i forgot
you're still alive
so i asked elon musk if he thinks living
in a world where one man has one
trillion dollars and the other people
die of hunger is a good world
what ensued was a ton of attacks from
the sympathizers of elon musk calling me
all sorts of things from communist to
idiot my question is this
where do you think all this
aggressiveness and rich man idolatry is
coming from why are people so aggressive
why are people so obsessed with money
and why are people so rude and violent
well i'm not going to give you a fully
blown theory of why people are rude and
violent i think you know this is a
difficult question and
one point to keep in mind is that you
have an extremely strong selection
effect here it's not that people are
rude and violent just so that you you
know poked a certain hornet's nest that
has some very rude and violent people in
it and and you uh
got a reaction that is was kind of
predictable to be honest uh now why
those people exist at all you know it's
a more complicated psychological
question the reason why i wanted to
address this question is
i think that you know we have a
weird relationship in modern society
with the concept of super rich people
with billionaires or whatever
in part because
we haven't a lot of inequality in
society and it's it's getting to be too
much inequality it's we have both uh
very ostentatiously wealthy people and a
lot of people who are struggling we have
a societal system that makes it really
really hard to
climb out of very very low income
situations it's just too easy to get
into debt
uh to spiral downward like life is much
more expensive for poor people than it
is for rich people in a very real sense
because as a fraction of whatever income
they have um there are fixed costs that
rich people can just laugh off and poor
people can't you know parking tickets
are a big deal when you're poor and what
you do is you end up not paying them and
then they grow right or overdraft fees
on the bank we literally charge you
money for not having enough money
whereas a rich person doesn't care about
parking tickets right like they can
laugh it off and still go make more
money off of their investments or
whatever it is
and that kind of system that has this
built-in
stratification dynamics to it is
troubling if you don't have a lot of uh
economic and social mobility built in so
i think that people are upset for a lot
of good reasons um and other people are
aspirational other people want to be
those rich people right who are very
very successful so
i don't i think that their
the conversation about wealthy people
has become too polarized honestly like
they're just people
you know like i know elon i'm not we're
not best buddies but i've met him i
argued with him on twitter about
extraterrestrial life and talking about
the previous ama question uh and he said
nice things about my books that's good i
think that he's a person like i know
lots of people who are quite wealthy and
there's good ones and bad ones smart
ones and dumb ones uh good ones and evil
ones
uh i think that is possible with respect
to elon musk to both say
um you know to criticize him to say we
don't like how
tesla workers are treated or you know
the ability to unionize or something
like that or the the fact that he
doesn't want to pay his fair share of
taxes
while also recognizing that uh he has
almost single-handedly
done more to change the world than
almost anyone else i can think of by
really like converting a whole industry
from
gas engines to electric cars that was
unthinkable a short time ago and you
know without elon that probably would
not have happened so i think that people
are complicated i think that we should
develop the mental capacities to have
nuanced views of human beings and when
it comes to rich people that's becoming
harder people either
want to worship them like you say you
know to hero worship them or to vilify
them and i'm not in favor of either one
of these
i don't want to hero worship anybody
i have a general theory of not hero
worshiping people
uh you know i don't worship richard
feynman or albert einstein or martin
luther king or ruth bader ginsburg or
whoever you want to pick i think it's
just a bad idea people you can admire
people for what they've done but hero
worship involves extending that
admiration to you know a general feeling
that they're good people just because
they did this one good thing and that's
just setting yourself up for
disappointment you know a person can
both change the world and be bad in
other ways and you have to be able to
accept those nuances there
in fact liam kofi bright who was on the
podcast uh
when i first invited him on the podcast
i wanted to talk about this because he
has a whole uh spiel about how we should
have no heroes which is very interesting
and compelling we got distracted talking
about truth but you can look that up on
his website um but i don't want to
villainize villainize yeah villainize uh
rich people either you know i'm reminded
of
alexandra
or ocasio or cortez aoc
remember she went to the met gala this
happened a few weeks ago or months ago
so she went to the scala full of rich
people and she wore a dress and on the
back of the dress was written tax the
rich okay and now
do me a favor just for a moment put
aside whatever pre-existing feelings you
might have about aoc or the tax system
or the met gala or whatever i want to
make one very small specific point okay
people
objected on the basis that it was
hypocritical or somehow there was some
tension between the fact that she was at
a party full of rich people
and had a dress that said tax the rich
okay
and i objected to this objection this
makes no sense this is not in any sense
hypocritical or even slightly tense it
is no contradiction whatsoever
to hang out with rich people have a
party with them and have a good time and
also think they should pay more taxes
those two things are completely
compatible with each other the only way
the only reason why you might think that
they're incompatible with each other is
if you think that the fact that rich
people should pay more taxes is a
reflection of the fact that we don't
like them that they are bad or they are
evil and that's why we want to tax them
more and i don't think that at all like
i said rich people are just people you
know they're the same span of abilities
and virtues that other people have
i want to be rich myself i want everyone
else to be rich that's what i want i
don't want to get rid of rich people i
want everyone to be rich that's the
thing i think that we should be aiming
for
um
but i also want the current rich people
to pay more taxes because
rich people are part of society and
benefit from society in very very
obvious ways like of course you can
inherit money and then we can talk about
the justice of that that's a perfectly
good set of questions but if you made
money to become a billionaire
it's not because you worked really hard
at your job in walmart no walmart worker
ever saved up enough money to become a
billionaire that has literally never
happened what happened is you either
invented a system or you participated in
some existing system
to arrange for a billion people to give
you a dollar each roughly speaking at
the end of the day or maybe you know 100
million people gave you 10 each there's
different ways to work it but
the point is that the only way to
accumulate a billion dollars
is is if a lot of people send you their
money
it only happens if you're embedded in a
system that allows that to happen a
system with
people but also roads and education and
commerce systems and you know the whole
supply chain that we talked about with
christopher mims a couple of episodes
ago
and it is completely fair for society
then to say in return
give us some of the money you know we
set up a system that allowed you to make
this money now we want to keep the
system working give us up some of the
money
asking rich people to pay taxes is not a
bad thing okay it's it's certainly not
unnecessary
even if you think it's a bad thing you
shouldn't mix it up
with some distaste for the idea of rich
people at all i think that's just
entirely misguided and it's a reflection
of this idea that every intellectual
disagreement has to become a moral
emotional stance and i think that's a
bad
attitude so anyway i got very far away
from your question robert sorry about
that and i probably haven't even
answered your question but your question
provoked me to say some things and
that's how i treat these amas these days
division
says
i was thinking that borrowing some
physics jargon can bypass some of the
free will discussion pitfalls at least
among physicists in particular do you
think that the apparent conflict of the
phrase could have done otherwise with
determinism can be avoided by separating
the off-shell and the on-shell
descriptions i was tempted to think of
this way
when i read the classic freedom of the
will and concept of a person paper by
frankfurt which i think is essentially
formulating the concept of free will as
the existence of degrees of freedom for
the human will albeit in a different
language
um
my guess is no my first guess like maybe
there's a theory to be developed here
that you want to go and develop but it
that is not the way that i think about
free will even if i were to restrict
myself to physics jargon um i don't
think that's the main point so for those
of you who don't know the physics jargon
think of a particle moving through the
air right you know you all know the
classic example when we learn classical
physics newtonian mechanics you throw up
a ball with a certain velocity and given
the acceleration due to gravity it
travels on some kind of parabolic
trajectory and you can calculate what
that trajectory is okay
so the fact that the ball moves along a
certain trajectory both its position as
a function of time and its momentum as a
function of time obey equations of
motion that's how we say it and there
are reasons which i'm not going to go
into from particle physics that when you
obey the equations of motion in that way
we say that you are on shell you are on
the mass shell you are obeying certain
equations
um it's not it's more complicated than
that but i'm just trying to get you the
essence of it if you if you don't
already know whereas off shell means you
don't necessarily obey the equations of
motion we can imagine
all sorts of trajectories for a particle
through space that don't obey the
equations of motion that the real
physical particles would obey
so what device is getting at is
even given some fixed initial conditions
uh we can distinguish between the actual
behavior of the system that obeys the
initial conditions from
sorry that starts with those initial
conditions and obeys the equations of
motion from some more arbitrary random
kind of uh motion
but i think that that's not the right
distinction to make because i think that
the point is that we don't know the
initial conditions in the real world
right like if the world were just a
simple harmonic oscillator if that was
the whole world or if the whole world
were just a few planets moving around
the sun
there'd be zero reason to talk about
free will in any sense because you can
just see what happens and it's pretty
clear and you can predict what's going
to happen
the reason why free will if you believe
it is if you're a compatibilist if you
believe it's a useful concept is because
human beings are so complicated that we
don't know their initial conditions
so we don't know what they're going to
do so we invent concepts to describe
both their current state and their
possible future actions
and those concepts involve things like
reasons and choices and deliberations
okay and this is part of how we talk
about human beings and as i've said many
times before even the most devoted free
will skeptic uses those words they can't
help but talk about human beings free
will skeptics are constantly trying to
decide trying to persuade you to behave
in certain ways which is slightly
incompatible with their underlying
metaphysical view of the world but
that's why it's easier to be a
compatibilist
and the formulation of free will as i
could have done otherwise
i think is completely consistent with a
deterministic universe and everything
obeying the equations of motion in other
words you don't need to go off shell to
explain it because the point is you
don't know
what the initial conditions are you know
some basic macroscopic coarse-grained
features of the system but not all the
microscopic details so to me the
question of could you have behaved
differently the reason why freewill
skeptics get it wrong in my view
is they formulate the question could the
system have behaved differently
as if we had exactly the microscopic
information about the state
and in that case the answer would be no
the system could not have behaved
differently but we don't have that
information so the right question to ask
is given the macroscopic information we
have about the system
in the space of all possible microscopic
configurations that fit into that
macroscopic description are there some
that would act this way and are there
some that would act that way and if the
answer is yes then that corresponds in
the higher level vocabulary to
you could have acted differently that's
where i think is the right connection
between free will and the underlying
laws of physics
chris says what do you think are the
most important things to know not in
science but in life in general
so this is not going to be very clever
or original but i'm going to give a sort
of a teach you how to fish kind of
answer like i don't think there's a set
of facts that are the important things
to know i think the most important
things to know are how to learn things
right techniques for gaining new
knowledge because then rather than just
giving you some knowledge i think you
should have if i teach you to learn
things then you can get knowledge for
yourself um so i don't know what those
things are i mean basically the answer
is along the lines of
techniques for gathering information
about the world converting them into
models and hypotheses testing them and
being a good scientist about it okay
um
in the broadest possible sense so i'm
going to include you know human
relations and things like that in that
in that set of things you know the
theories that i'm talking about
developing are not just theories for how
people behave but you know your theories
for how you should behave how to get
ahead how to live a meaningful life to
develop purposes and and how to matter
to other people and and be nice those
are all things you need to learn and so
that's what i would hope that you would
start out by knowing
napoleon's corporal says dna passes on
physical traits and the specific genes
that carry these traits can be
identified but what about behavioral
traits can we identify genes that result
in things like the herding instinct that
sheltiy dogs have bred been bred to have
the broader question here is how can any
physical thing influence something like
behavior well i don't know
any specific examples of um
uh dna
uh base pairs that are correlated or
even the genes that are caused with
specific behaviors but a hundred percent
they exist yeah i mean that's that is
absolutely something that
neuroscientists and psychologists etc
geneticists do figure out
and i i'm honestly i'm not quite sure
what you mean by how can a physical
thing influence something like behavior
what else influences behavior you know
the behavior of the ball is influenced
by the fact that i throw it right
physical things influence behavior
that's the
behavior is a way of talking about what
physical things do i think so i'm not
even quite sure what the what you're
what you're worried about there
alexandra bates says do you believe
there are certain traits or paradigms
that separate scientific theories from
pseudoscientific ones or do you believe
all theories have the same capacity to
be scientific and what makes themselves
their agreement with the data
no actually i think you know
i don't think there's a hard fast line
you know people would love it if they
could find a single way to demarcate
scientific theories from non-scientific
theories and the the there's a name for
this the demarcation problem uh i don't
think it's gonna be quite that easy i
think it's more of a sliding scale um
and i've famously pointed out that karl
popper's attempt to answer this question
by talking about falsifiability uh is
not up to the task because i don't think
anything is up to the task but i do
think that that popper was on to
something as i also often say and people
ignore that part um what he was on to
was there are two properties that good
scientific theories tend to have one is
that they're definite
that they're incompatible with some
things a good scientific theory is not
one size fits all a good scientific
theory says that some things happen and
some things don't
and the reason why this is
philosophically not crystal clear is
because when you talk about
falsifiability
then you're taking this
this
ontological feature of the theory some
things happen and some things don't and
turning it into an epistemological
theory i can see some things happen or
not see them happen and learn about it
right and that's where things get
fuzzier because if the things that
happen are other universes
then they might very definitely happen
or not happen but you can't observe them
so that's where it gets a little bit
messy but nevertheless the basic idea
that a scientific theory is definite
that it says certain things happen and
certain things don't i think is
absolutely part of scientific theory and
the other thing that i think pupper was
right about you know in his direction
that he was trying to move in is
we ultimately judge scientific theories
empirically we do not intuit our way to
the right answer or at least we don't
intuit our way to knowing that the
answer is right we have to test them
against the data so scientific theories
are not ideas that had to be right right
they're not deductive arguments from a
priori principles to correct answers
they are hypotheses that are tested
hypotheses that we put forward and we
assign a credence to and then the
credence goes up or down on the basis of
observations and collecting and
collecting new data about the universe
so i don't think that there is a simple
clear dividing line but i think that
these two properties of being definite
and being amenable to empirical
testing are two parts of being a good
scientific theory
liam mccarty says why do you think some
ways of solving a given problem are
easier than other ways i'm sure part of
it has to do with human psychology but
i'm wondering if there's more to it than
that for example arguably feynman
diagrams are more efficient than
schwinger integrals and newton's laws
are more efficient than einstein's field
equations in a particular regime
perhaps we could define such notion of
efficiency for problem-solving approach
or physical theory maybe there are
complexity classes of the sort here not
for different problems but for the same
way of solving a single problem
so this is similar to the previous
question about a metric on the space of
operations on functions or something
like that um
i'm i'm sure that human psychology
plays some role here i mean human beings
are specific arrangements of stuff and
specific ways of thinking so it would be
weird if the specific kind of thought
process that went on in human brains
had nothing to do with why some problems
are harder than some and some are easier
but having said that i think we tend to
over
rate that aspect of the issue you know i
think that
uh there are some aspects of problems
that are just hard this is this is you
know if you just say the initial
question you asked is
why are some ways of solving a given
problem easier than other ways
um this is very closely related to
complexity classes complexity classes
are about how many steps it takes to
solve a problem rather than different
ways of solving the problem but
complexity classes are usually about the
minimum number of steps it can take and
this is a pretty objective fact right i
mean if it takes a certain number of
steps to solve the problem it doesn't
matter whether it's a human being doing
it or a dolphin or a computer okay so i
think that uh we tend to not
credit enough the fundamental aspects of
the problem and we tend to leap too
quickly to some particular fact of human
psychology when we think about these
things
um but the basic question that you're
asking why are some ways easier than
others you know i i i'm not gonna give
you the right answer i don't even know
how to formulate
what an answer would look like but i
will again make the
point that it probably has to do with
the features of the problem more than
the features of the human brain most of
the
time p walder says is the interference
pattern observed in young's split yeah
young's slit experiment to be considered
as evidence for the many world's
interpretation of reality uh nope
because the double slit experiment is
predicted by any decent interpretation
of quantum mechanics so therefore it
literally cannot possibly count as
evidence for many worlds i mean you
might think that the explanation for it
in many worlds is nicer or more
attractive or whatever but you know as a
bayesian what if the likelihood that you
will get that data given the theory is
equal in many worlds or bohmian
mechanics or any other respectable
theory of quantum mechanics because if
you didn't predict the double-slit
experiment correctly you would not have
gotten off the ground no one who paid it
would have paid attention to you
lucas der hashing says
i've been recently looking into some of
the cosmic speed limit postulated by
minkowski it's quite interesting to find
out that we all move through space-time
at the speed of light my question is
if we would completely stop moving
through space how fast would time go by
so i think that i'm going to disagree
with your middle sentence there we do
not move through space-time at the speed
of light uh i don't know who said that
i'm not even sure what it means and you
know how fast does time go by it always
goes by one second per second that's the
only
speed at which time can possibly go by
and that's true whether you're speeding
or staying still or in a gravitational
field or not
uh there's no such thing as the speed
with which we move through space-time
the idea of a speed
is the amount of distance we travel as a
function of time that's what speed is so
it just doesn't apply to going through
space-time um it's a different kind of
thing and i'm not going to go into many
details here but this is just something
you have to wrap your mind around when
you really get into what is meant by
special relativity and the interval in
space-time and why the twin paradox
works um i will recommend reading the
book that i just wrote and will
eventually come out like a year from now
uh that explains these things in great
detail or failing that you could just
check out the videos right on the
biggest ideas in the universe
marco tausser says my question is
how is an electron's wave function
different from the electron field do you
picture them differently in your mind
uh well they are different um they're
very different in fact but there's sort
of a limit in which they become kind of
similar to each other and that limit is
where the field is only vibrating enough
to give you a single electron and
honestly there's
technicalities that arise with electrons
that make me reluctant to talk about
that it has to do with the difference
between fermions and bosons and it's
harder although not impossible to talk
about the electron field in sort of
classical visualizable terms because of
the exclusion principle because you can
only have one
fermion like an electron doing the same
thing at the same time it's easier to
talk about a bosonic field like
the photon field or the higgs field or
something like that
but the point is that when you have the
quantum field which is the more
fundamental thing then you have a wave
function of that quantum field and the
single field can describe any number of
particles right it's not just one
electron or one whatever higgs boson or
photon it's any collection of these
things can be described by the wave
function of that single field but then
when you
boil it down when you say okay i'm only
going to be interested
in configurations of the field or wave
functions of the field that represent a
single particle
then there's really no the the
difference between the wave function in
the field kind of dissolves not exactly
certainly in the case of the
electromagnetic field uh it does not
dissolve very well because the
electromagnetic field is a vector and
it's real valued it is not a complex
valued scalar number like the wave
function is but my point is the only the
only useful thing i'm trying to say here
is that
the wave function of the field is a much
bigger grander thing it can describe not
just one particle at a time but any
collection of particles including the
creation and dilation of particles
that's one of the crucial features of
quantum field theory so the single
electron is sort of a limit that you get
and then the the in that case the
distinction between the electron wave
functional and the electron field uh
becomes a little bit harder to
distinguish
dan o'neill says what are we
i like these big questions
when i think of the four-dimensional
space-time of relativity theory and how
the passing of time is just an illusion
i think we must be the braided world
lines of all the particles that have
made up our bodies over the course of
our lifetimes
then when i remember the questionable
status of a particle in quantum
mechanics i think we must be an inter
intricate inter rippling of quantum wave
functions but then when i remember the
problem of the wavefunction collapse the
solution posed by many worlds i try to
picture myself as a massively complex
branching bush of wave functions in an
unpicturably vast multiverse ignoring
immersion properties is this what a
human being is if so do you see it as a
remarkable perhaps beautiful phenomenon
even at this fundamental level
so there's one problem with your
question dan which is you say ignoring
emergent properties is this what a human
being is
but a human being is emerging property
there's there's no human beings in the
fundamental
ontology of the world right i mean if
you're a uh modern particle physicist
you would say the fundamental ontology
of the world is quantum field theory if
you're even more extreme like myself you
would say it's just a vector in hilbert
space it's a single quantum wave
function but either way
there's no human beings there right
human beings are concepts that only make
sense at the higher emergent level so
you can't say tell me what a human being
is but don't talk about the higher
emergent level that's just not fair
and it's also crucial to actually
answering the question more seriously
because
as i said in different contexts you can
always take
the purely microscopic point of view
and just never talk about higher level
emergent concepts and this is what you
would do if you were a laplace's demon
right if you literally knew the exact
microstate of the universe and how it
evolved over time
you wouldn't need to talk about these
higher levels you know you wouldn't need
to describe the earth going around the
sun as just its center of mass and its
center of velocity you would talk about
every single particle in the earth why
not you have access to it all if you
have that fundamental microscopic
description
you can purely talk in that language so
the question of what is a human being
is by its nature
a question about the relationship of the
higher levels including the ones that
have human beings as part of them to the
lower levels
and there might not be a unique answer
because it might depend on exactly which
levels you're comparing to each other so
you know it's perfectly okay to talk
about human beings in a single world at
a time you know you can you can know you
can be convinced that the fundamental
theory of reality predicts there are
copies of you being made all the time
but you can still talk about the one
that is in the world that you're in
right now that's okay and you don't need
to worry about all these other ones
there's certainly once they've branched
off they're not you anymore right they
are descendants of your past you but
they are not related to your present you
in any uh useful way
so i think that uh
to correctly tackle this i'm not giving
you the right answer to this question
because i think it's a tricky one and
probably not a unique one but to think
about this question in a useful way
requires taking seriously inviting the
bullet about these higher emergent
levels you can't really get around them
chris murray says near the end of the
biggest ideas in the universe q a number
nine fields you introduce the re
schleider theorem can you make an
educated guess as to what a person on a
space station would see if they looked
up at the taj mahal being created on the
moon from acting on the fields somewhere
on earth so the rich lighter theorem is
a reflection of the fact that
in quantum field theory in the vacuum
state
the fields in any one region of space
are entangled with fields everywhere
else
in any other region of space all
throughout the universe okay at least
if you're truly in the vacuum which
maybe you're not and if it's just
minkowski space which we know we're not
but anyway something like that is is
likely to be true and because of that
because of that entanglement you know
how if you have two particles that are
owned by alice and bob and they're
entangled with each other making a
measurement on one particle tells you
something about what the other particle
is going to be doing even if you don't
know it immediately might take time for
an any information about what is going
on to go back and forth but something
happens
um
the difference is that in quantum field
theory
even in one small region of space you
don't just have a spin that is up or
down
in quantum field theory you literally
have an infinite number
of things that could be going on in one
region of space you have fields that
could take on literally any value there
might be a probability that they take on
certain values or certain other ones if
you were to observe them and there is uh
but every value is represented okay
there's an infinite number of
possibilities and this is one of the
reasons why i don't think quantum field
theory is right that's kind of a lot to
put into one tiny region of space an
infinite number of possibilities
so this infinite number of possibilities
is entangled with infinite numbers of
possibilities at every other region of
every other point in the universe so the
reach slider theorem says that when you
make a measurement
on a region of on the quantum fields in
some region of space one possible
outcome
is to bring into existence somewhere
else in the universe literally anything
in the alice and bob with spin's case by
measuring
your spin up or down you bring into
existence the spin is either up or down
whereas it was for bob's particle even
though it wasn't a superposition
um
in the quantum field theory case
empty space can be thought of as a
superposition of all sorts of crazy
things and you don't notice it because
it's in the superposition that gives you
a minimum energy but in principle there
is a measurement outcome that
corresponds to bringing into existence a
copy of the taj mahal on the moon
that is why the reece schleider theorem
is sometimes called the taj mahal
theorem and so the question is what
would that look like
you know the honest question is
um it could look like almost anything
because
that's part of the theorem right like on
the one hand you bring into existence
the taj mahal on the moon on the other
hand there are some photons that travel
from the taj mahal to you
and guess what they could be anything
because you could bring anything into
existence you know the the whole point
of the theorem is you're supposed to
suspend your interest in the probability
that any of these things actually happen
you're just proving rigorous
mathematical theories about what could
happen so what could you see
anything literally anything
but the probability that you see
anything at all is gonna be very very
small the probability of the taj mahal
exists at any uh it comes into existence
is extraordinarily small this is
absolutely a case where just because
something in principle could happen i
wouldn't worry about it in any realistic
way
nate wadoops says
standard sirens came up in an episode
that i listened to last month
what are the forces that come together
to tune them to standard behavior i mean
what why do they all act the same rather
than being random sirens so the point of
standard sirens is you're imagining two
black holes that are coalescing okay
just like we observed it in ligo or
whatever the point is in a typical ligo
event what you don't know is the
redshift because you don't have any um
visible light coming from them to get a
redshift you need visible photons that
have spectral lines that you can ask how
redshifted they are so what you're
really looking for is the special
subclass of events that have both
gravitational waves
and electromagnetic radiations you can
measure a redshift to them
then the point is that
you can figure out the distance if all
goes well and you get enough data in
principle in practice this hasn't been
done yet but you know they're working on
it
the point is that you can
follow the hole in spiral right so it's
not just you see a blip you see a wave
that grows
over the course of a few seconds and
then chirps okay
and so you see both the total amount of
time it takes for that to happen and you
see the frequency right you see the the
space between the different peaks and
the amplitude of the wave and how it
develops over time so that's actually a
pretty good amount of information and
from that if all goes well you can
discern the actual masses
of the um in spiraling black holes and
so you can predict the the amplitude of
those gravitational waves and therefore
you compare that the amplitude you
actually observe
and you get the distance okay
so the reason why they're standard is
just because there's only all that's
happening is gravity with two black
holes there's not a lot of degrees of
freedom not a lot of weirdness right
it's not like a star that can have
different chemical composition inside or
different being a different environment
with different accretion disks or
anything like that it's two black holes
that have two masses that's literally
almost all the degrees of freedom it's
not quite because
they can be tilted and they can be
spinning so it's a little bit more
complicated than that but in principle
you can work all that out
and there's certain special cases where
you have
reason to believe that
it's even simpler than that so you can
have more confidence in your
reconstruction of what the masses were
and therefore the amplitudes and
therefore the distance to the thing um
so really the ultimate answer is you're
looking at a very simple system two
black holes
that are being very simple direct set of
equations the equations of general
relativity most things in the world are
not that simple it goes back to the very
first question the ama black holes have
no hair there's not a lot of details
when it comes to describing black holes
teresa robeson says in your opinion what
are the couple of a couple of the most
indispensable science magazines for the
layperson
to read to keep abreast of recent
scientific research and advances
um yeah i don't know honestly like um
my science my popular science
input comes actually mostly from twitter
because i follow science journalists and
scientists on twitter and when something
interesting happens they link to it and
so then i will click on it and it might
be wherever it is so i don't like
regularly go to the homepages of
magazines or subscribe to magazines the
magazines i subscribe to are like the
new york review books or something like
that right like not specifically science
or physics magazines i will put in a
plug for two of my favorites one of them
is rs technica because my wife jennifer
writes for them so you can trust them
absolutely and the other of course is
quanta quantum magazine does a very very
good job
at modern physics and math and so forth
if anything it likes math a little bit
too much so if you don't think there's
enough math in your popular science diet
i would definitely check out quanta but
the great thing about quanta is they
really care about the ideas they're not
it's not a you know excuse to write
profiles of scientific heroes or you
know things like that it's really about
sometimes quite abstract ideas in math
and physics they tackle things
that um other
science outlets will not tackle if you
you know the firewalls paradox have you
ever heard of the firewalls paradox and
black hole physics jennifer actually
wrote
an article for quanta about that it was
the first article about the firewall
problem to appear in the popular media
because everyone else was afraid of
doing it
the quanta but jennifer would tackle it
and quantum would publish it so it
appeared there and the new york times
came along a few months after that and
then it caught on even more broadly than
that
michael shillingford says pre-socratic
philosophers used to debate whether
reality was made up of discrete things
eg atomism or stuff like water i've
recently seen a similar argument
centered around particles and fields
which ontology is correct between things
and stuff or is it a defective debate
um
yeah you know i think that there's it
depends what do you mean here so
uh
there's the question of the ultimate
ontology of the world which i've
recently written a paper saying it's a
vector in hilbert space that's what i
claim that is our best current
understanding of it um but
to get there you know we work through
various levels of description and
there's absolutely
on much more solid ground a level of
description which is the quantum field
theory level so i will take your
question to be
at that level of quantum field theory at
the best tested version of fundamental
physics we currently have uh what does
the fundamental ontology look like and
unsurprisingly given that it's called
quantum field theory it's a theory of
fields but it's a theory of the quantum
theory of fields not the classical
theory okay let's take that but it is
definitely not a theory of particles and
you know this is a case where
um
physicists and philosophers kind of
think about things differently because
philosophers think there is a debate
about whether or not the fundamental
ontology is more particle-like or
field-like and they debate it physicists
for the most part know it's all fields
and they just think it's fields and it's
not real really much of a debate and
part of it is because the the difference
is
you start with the quantum theory of
particles
and you can kind of bootstrap your way
up into a quantum theory of fields by
insisting that the particles can be able
to interact with each other and
annihilate and create and so forth so
many body physicists do that not many
body physicists but many body physicists
or you can go the other way you can
start with the theory of fields quantize
it show that you get particles out in
the low energy perturbative limit so it
seems like they're on an equal footing
in some sense um but
if you take the field
uh perspective seriously there are
non-perturbative effects
a particle is a tiny fluctuation in a
quantum field and so it's an appropriate
concept to think about when the field is
nearly quiet right it's a tiny
perturbation around that quiet vacuum
state but sometimes fields do big
things collective things that are not
tiny
perturbations in any sense they they do
non-perturbative things like when the
higgs boson field rolls from a value of
zero to its non-zero expectation value
in the vacuum that's a big
non-perturbative thing that's easy to
understand from the field theory
perspective it's almost impossible to
make sense of that if you thought the
world were fundamentally made of
particles and not of fields so for those
reasons particle physicists tend to
think that really the world is made of
fields but there could be something else
underlying the whole thing as i said
okay gregory kusnick says should parents
lie to their kids about santa claus
if they want to i don't care you know
there's bigger problems in the world to
worry about for one thing but i think
that there is a danger that people can
fetishize always telling the truth a
little bit too much okay you know i try
to be a reasonable person about this i
care about the truth
but that doesn't mean that there is uh
there's some sort of kantian
principle that says that you should only
ever tell the truth and never lie no
matter what the consequences might be
if someone just got their hair cut and
says
don't you think it looks nice
just say it looks nice who cares what
you actually think right if they say
should i get my hair cut in this way or
that way and it hasn't yet happened then
you know by all means be honest but if
it's already there and they're just
looking for some reassurance not really
a judgment or an opinion or a helpful
fact they can use to make a decision be
nice say the nice thing to them likewise
if your kid is five years old and is
excited about santa claus tell them
santa claus is going to come and give
him presents that's fine you know most
people
who i know who grew up in this sort of
same environment that i grew up in we
all thought that santa claus was real we
were very very young kids none of us
were seriously brain damaged or
psychologically
uh impacted by the realization
eventually that it wasn't true and if
you don't want to tell them that santa
claus is real and you want to tell them
the truth go ahead and tell them that
too that's also fine
naroon narasimhachar says do you see a
problem with basing day-to-day
epistemology ethics and other essential
aspects of human life on very rigorous
calculi
bayesianism or utilitarianism while it
is possible to do due diligence to these
calculi in academic research
implementing them in their pure form in
our daily lives require impractical
amounts of thought computation and
possibly knowledge are there
philosophers who seriously work on
developing heuristic only versions of
such calculi this is calculated in the
sense of plural of calculus by the way
in case you're wondering
that are both feasible for everyday use
and robust against variations in the
user's backgrounds etc
um i mean basically yes i i do agree
with the thrust here um
in the following sense and i think i've
said this in other contexts but i think
that
um in many ways the fact that human
beings are found are
bounded finite beings computationally
and informationally
circumscribed um is really really
important we don't either have the time
or the capacity to do perfect reasoning
about anything we will always be using
heuristics etc
and you know this fact has been put to
use
in psychology and things like that for
example remember the podcast with carl
fristen
who thinks about the bayesian brain and
the free energy principle and the free
energy principle is a way to sort of
make sense of what the brain does
thinking that it's trying to be a good
bayesian reasoner but it doesn't have
perfect resources to do that so the free
energy principle is sort of a shortcut
to do bayesian updating to get a picture
of the world
and
i absolutely think that in the real
world um there are
going to be constraints
on how precise we can be and how precise
we can reason another relevant podcast
episode is the one with elizabeth
anderson where she talks about ideal
theory
this is an ongoing debate right now in
moral and political philosophy
how useful is it
to
figure out how to be better morally or
politically
by first imagining how to be perfect it
will be the ideal society etc and then
moving in that direction i mean that's a
that's a feasible thing to say right if
we knew what the perfect society was and
we know what our society is now we could
say good let's move to make things
closer to the perfect society and i
think that would work
what anderson says and what other people
would argue is
there's no such thing as the ideal
theory because you know as the real
society changes or as conditions change
you might learn more or change your mind
about what you want society to be it's
much more feasible to talk about how we
can start with where we are and make
things a little bit better
than to start with where we are and say
well over there is the perfect thing
let's move in that direction i think a
similar thing is probably true for more
everyday life kinds of things you know
how should i
choose what to do from day to day or
even make big picture decisions about
getting married or choosing a new job or
having kids or something like that
there will always be heuristics involved
and and the short answer is i don't know
of
detailed philosophical investigation but
exactly focus on exactly that feature of
day-to-day decision-making but uh that's
not to say it's not out there it might
just be out there and i'm not aware of
it
emmett francis says any thoughts on some
strategies for maintaining good mental
health as a graduate student or as an
academic more generally from my
experience as a current phd student and
from talking to other grad students i
know a lot of us struggle with imposter
syndrome anxiety from the pressure to
publish or perish etc
i don't know if i have great
thoughts on strategies for that i'm very
sympathetic to the issue
uh i
like to say i think that graduate school
should actually be fun
i mean there's no question it should be
a challenge you know it should be
pushing you to your limits but in a
healthy and rewarding way
uh
very few people go to graduate school in
something like theoretical physics for
the fame and fortune right they go to
into it because they love the material
the topic the subject matter and if that
love is squeezed out of you by uh being
in some sort of psychological pressure
cooker then it's it's not doing what
it's supposed to be doing
there are absolutely abusive
advisors and mentors and lab pis etc
that if possible you should stay away
from so this is one of the things you
should take very seriously when you're
looking at possible graduate schools
not only which is the most intellectual
powerhouse but of the potential advisors
of the places you're looking at do they
treat their students well you know what
are the reports back from the students
who are there
um
you know having said that there are
certain there are certain things that
are always going to be true about the
graduate school experience
not only is it hard to learn the things
you need to learn
to be a successful phd but
usually you enter graduate school hoping
to become a professor and there are not
that many professor jobs it's a it's a
very tight market and there's just
nothing to be done about that there will
always be more people who want those
jobs than there are jobs it's like being
a concert pianist or a professional
basketball player you know there's a lot
of people who want that and the
competition is is very stiff to do it
you know in some sense as difficult as
graduate school is it's a lot easier
than trying to make a living as a
hollywood actor
because at least graduate school postdoc
et cetera is a clear-cut set of steps
that you can go through and it's either
up or out right either you succeed or
you're it's clear you should get a job
doing something else whereas if you're
an actor musician etc
you can struggle for years and never
know and it might be the tomorrow you
get a big break it's a lot more random
and a lot less structured so hold on to
that as a little shiny beacon of hope
but um
otherwise you know
what can i say uh other than not
choosing um uh uh
an abusive advisor even if you choose a
really nice advisor people can still put
pressure on themselves like you say
there's imposter pressure imposter
syndrome there's the
competition
to eventually get jobs and things like
that i don't have good advice there i
really don't and i'm sorry because i
think that i care a lot about the mental
health of
students i try to make my own students
you know if anything i don't push my
students hard enough because i know that
it's hard and i let them push themselves
and
that's a tricky thing as an advisor like
for one thing by the way you get no
advice on how to be an advisor right no
one teaches you how to do it so it's a
hard thing to do because
you have a tremendous impact on the
lives of future lives of your students
when you're an advisor and you have no
training and how to do a good job at it
and one of the things that's crucially
important about being an advisor is that
different students need different kinds
of advising
some students are better if they're if
their advisor is hands off and they let
them do their own thing others really
need to be guided others need to be
constantly encouraged others need to be
told you know nope you're slacking off
try to do better and it's it's hard to
know ahead of time what the right
strategy is so even if your advisor
seems to be taking the wrong strategy
don't necessarily blame them because you
know they're not experts in this game
either
um
you know i think that
if i'm going to give one piece of advice
when it's not very helpful i i know but
i'm going to give it anyway which is to
just do your best not to lose sight of
whatever that little bit of delight and
passion and wonder it was that got you
in to this field in the first place like
if you went to grad school because you
didn't know what else to do
then i don't know what to tell you but i
think most people go to grad school
because they're really passionate about
the material they want to learn
about this stuff and hopefully increase
the total amount of human knowledge
about this stuff
and that's what to keep in mind not
comparing yourself to other people or
worrying about the job market or
whatever
getting a phd whether or not you get a
job as a professor ultimately down the
road is an intrinsically worthwhile
endeavor
it's uh
you know it's like climbing a mountain
right you know it's an obstacle there
that is maybe a little artificial but
there's a sense of accomplishment upon
doing it and it's better than climbing a
mountain because you learn something
that is really useful for other purposes
uh i don't want to disparage mountain
climbers sorry about that but uh you
know it's you you you get something out
of it that is both the sense of
accomplishment and something a little
bit more tangible so you know it's
always the comparisons with other people
that get you in trouble psychologically
here right i'm not good enough i'm not
going to get a job my advisor is mad at
me it's always those things that get you
in trouble the material the learning and
you know keep reminding yourself how
much more you know now than you did two
years ago right it's remarkable because
at any one moment from week to week it's
easy to lose track of the fact that
you're learning a lot but then you look
back a couple years you're like boy i
didn't know anything
two years ago and that's you know that
is a wonderful time of your life this
you know you're really learning to go
from being a student to being a
researcher when you're in graduate
school and that's just a singularly
wonderful
thing to get to do so imposter or not
um you know don't forget to be glad
that you're in this wonderful position
uh to really take advantage of the
intellectual life that humanity has been
able to cultivate for a few of its
people and not too many of them
jeff b says i was reading about lord
kelvin's idea that different atoms are
just different types of knots in the
ether although this is obviously false
can we think of string theory as a
quantized and relativized upgrade to
this idea or is there more to it
well there's definitely more to it but
maybe there's a family resemblance there
also i mean there's no ether so that's
that part is wrong
um and they're not knots you know
strings are generally not knotted uh
they're generally either single line
segments or circles okay they're not
tied uh topologically interesting ways
around each other if they did they would
just untie right away so they're neither
knots nor the ether but i know what you
mean i mean they're vibrating
one-dimensional things and the kinds of
vibrations
are what specify what kind of particle
it is what kind of field it is etc so
that's the family resemblance but you
know there's no direct intellectual
lineage from kelvin's idea to string
theory as you may know or may not
string theory arose in a really
backwards way right
they were trying to understand the
strong interactions
well there's a couple of different
threads that came together people were
trying to understand the strong
interactions there were certain patterns
in the observed
particles out there that particle
accelerators were giving us and people
were trying to fit them to different
functions and make predictions and so
forth then uh veneziano came up with a a
formula
that said uh you know he could predict
some of these patterns of masses and
spins
in the observed spectrum of particles
and then other people like leonard
suskind is one of them and from a very
different angle yoshiro nambu was was
one and goto his collaborator uh pointed
out that by starting with
one-dimensional strings and quantizing
them you could derive this veneziano
amplitude and they were still trying to
understand the strong interactions and
it failed it didn't work for the strong
interactions there's a little bit of
lingering remnant of it in the fact that
you take two quarks and stretch them
apart uh like a one-dimensional string
of gluon field stretches between them so
there's something slightly stringy about
the strong interactions but what we now
call string theory uh is a completely
different version of that that is gives
us gravity and things like that and
hopefully everything else but the strong
interactions come along for the ride
rather than being the central point none
of this has anything to do with what
kelvin was talking about so it's at most
a family resemblance rather than a
direct uh relationship
casey mahone says
i sense a stigma in our culture against
being single i'm starting to find that i
may be the kind of person that would
that would just prefer to be alone but
people seem to view this as childish
they wonder how you can really be an
adult if you don't have a partner to
build something with do you sense this
stigma and do you think that it is
justified
well i certainly don't think it's
justified i mean i get what you mean um
there's both sort of a deep sense and a
shallow sense the shallow sense is a lot
of our society's social um
activities are
constructed around the idea of being
part of a couple right or a family right
you know go to dinner
with your loved one or whatever or you
know show up
table for two or you know two people
hotel room or whatever it is you know we
we group society's functions around the
idea that either now or someday you're
going to be a member of a couple that is
true and then i think like you're
hinting at there is sort of a deeper
thing going on where people judge you
right it's not just we built uh
structures to make it easy to be part of
a couple but
it is assumed that you want to be part
of a couple and if you're not it's
because you failed in this universal
goal
it's not exactly the same but it's um
there's a close analogy with
the idea of being sexual versus being
asexual remember we did a podcast with
angela chen where she talked about how
difficult it is to realize that you're
asexual that you just don't have that
kind of relationship between love and
lust that most people have and society
is not built to deal with you and judges
you to be bad if you don't fit in this
is what society does society takes the
fact that human beings are very diverse
looks at the most common ways that human
beings are and judges those to be
correct and judges all the other ways to
be wrong and this is a flaw in how
society works
but
it's it's hard to hopefully we're
getting better at it etc there's a lot
of resistance to change along these
directions so
um it's certainly not justified like i
mean there's there's
softer but related uh prejudices against
you know not having kids for example
right it's assumed you should want to
have kids that's just what you want to
do getting married etc
what if you're in a couple and you don't
get married what if you're in a couple
for
the same couple for 50 years but don't
get married people will look at you
funny
what can you do be proud of who you are
in your individual peculiarities rather
than worrying about them it's not the
biggest kind of prejudice out there in
the world so i get that uh you might
feel like you're being judged but
lots of people are being judged for
different reasons and you just gotta
tell society to suck it up and deal with
it because you are who you are and you
like it that way
robert asks a priority question if our
current formulation of quantum mechanics
hasn't appeared to answer what happened
at or before the big bang the black hole
firewall and singularity questions is it
better to think of the wave function as
a complete description of quantum
mechanics or
that it needs to be modified to account
for these mysteries
um
you know so
good
this is the this gets to the issue of
quantum mechanics as a framework versus
a theory you know quantum mechanics is
not a theory
of physics it's a framework in which you
develop theories of physics just like
classical physics is not a theory all by
itself you can have the classical theory
of gravity of electromagnetism of the
simple harmonic oscillator whatever
likewise you have the quantum theory of
simple harmonic oscillator
electromagnetism gravity whatever you
have different versions of all these
different specific theories classical
versions and quantum versions so
when you struggle
to understand some particular quantum
mechanical phenomenon it is possible to
ask you know is this a case
where it's not just we haven't found the
right model within quantum mechanics but
that quantum mechanics itself
is not up to the task
maybe i mean in some sense that's what
stephen wolfram would say right if you
remember our um podcast with him
i don't see that at all i think that
quantum mechanics number one there's no
experimental problem with it at all in
other examples of times where we've had
to throw out a theory or improve upon it
there's always been some experimental
uh evidence that it wasn't quite fitting
but number two i don't think that we've
tried hard enough like it it seems to me
to be extremely premature
to say well we haven't quantized gravity
yet therefore quantum mechanics is wrong
we just haven't tried hard enough to
quantize gravity honestly like i know
there's a lot of people out there
working on quantum gravity but most of
them are still starting from some
classical theory and trying to quantize
it right i don't think that taking the
quantumness of it seriously has been
tried nearly hard enough so
uh that's why i am not in favor of doing
that quantum mechanics as a framework is
extremely robust and successful
and there's also the small data point
that people have tried to change it and
failed
it's really really hard to modify
quantum mechanics in a way that doesn't
immediately run afoul of something you
know about the world like you know the
speed of light limit or something like
that
um so you're welcome to try but there's
no experimental evidence that says you
have have to and there's a lot of uh
theoretical hurdles to overcome if
you're gonna give it a shot
anonymous says
regarding the many world's
interpretation of quantum mechanics is
information conserved in the same way
that energy is conserved uh yes in fact
precisely the same way namely in many
worlds both information and energy are
exactly conserved in the wave function
of the universe
they are not exactly conserved on
individual branches of the wave function
where
observers find themselves and this fact
is very very well known when it comes to
information
it is less well appreciated when it
comes to energy but i think as i
mentioned earlier in the in the uh ama
uh it is true energy can vary a little
bit from branch to branch of the wave
function
seth says did you did your discussion
with sylvia earle on the ramifications
of consuming animals
change your view of the morality of
animal consumption i think i might have
edited this badly
because we were talking specifically
about
sea animals right not not land animals
so the short answer is no um
sylvia earle had very
um
meaningful and important and interesting
things to say about the
health aspects of eating seafood both
your individual health as a person and
the health of the planet right i mean
there's the issue of uh you know
overfishing and ruining the resources
that we have in the oceans that's very
very important um and i think we should
take that seriously then there's the
extra issue of uh the the point she made
which is kind of very obvious in
retrospect but i had never really
thought about it before
that unlike uh if you if you're a meat
eater
as a human being and you eat you know
land animals most of the land animals or
even most of the
birds that we eat so chicken pork
beef whatever
these are themselves
uh vegetarians right herbivores they
they cows eat grass and wheat and things
like that okay they don't eat other
animals we don't eat
uh you know jaguars and um crocodiles
that much i guess we do eat crocodiles
sometimes but anyway most of the animals
that we eat for our daily diets are
themselves herbivores so
when chemicals
that we human beings
nastily or thoughtlessly put into the
environment uh go into the environment
you know they might there might be some
bad poisonous chemicals that fall onto
plants and then the cows eat them and
then we eat them but it's relatively
sparse all things considered whereas the
fish that we eat are themselves
carnivores right the fish we eat
generally eat other fish to live and
those fish eat other fish etc and what
happens is a focusing and a
concentrating effect that all the bad
chemicals in the oceans are consumed by
the little fishies or the plankton or
whatever and they keep getting consumed
by bigger and bigger fish and they don't
go away right so they get concentrated
in the fish that we eventually eat so
seafood can have a much higher level of
these toxic chemicals than our land food
can i think that was sylvia earle's
biggest point about the health aspects
of eating fish and so i think it did
certainly
uh make me think twice about the health
benefits of eating seafood because if
you think just if you don't think about
the toxic chemicals then seafood is is
thought of as a healthy thing to eat
right compared to uh bacon or hamburgers
or pizza um but when you do think about
those chemicals then it changes your
mind a little bit and so yeah i think
maybe uh it may be a little bit less
eager to eat seafood and count it as a
health move than i otherwise would have
okay i'm grouping two questions together
let's
see if i can remember why
sid huff says you've mentioned a few
times on previous amas that you had a
distinctly non-academic upbringing do
you think it was extra difficult for you
to succeed so well academically because
of that have you ever felt imposter
syndrome the sense that you don't really
know enough aren't really capable enough
to be where you are that somehow you
managed to fool everyone so far
and jim murphy says do you have any
advice about developing discipline i'm
always impressed by how much you were
able to do without seeming exhausted at
all uh so yeah i was reluctant to answer
both of these questions because i don't
like to talk about myself personally
that much i like to talk about you know
my ideas and so forth um but you know
look these are decent questions and
maybe we can help other people by
talking about them together um and i
especially like jim's question about how
impressed he is about i'm able to do so
much without seeming exhausted at all
because
man i am exhausted all the time and i'm
very happy to hear that it doesn't seem
that way
um you know especially yeah i'm really
good at just saying yes to requests to
do things that have deadlines in the
future and then being in trouble when
the deadlines get here and it can be
very exhausting and you know
there's a lot of things i want to do you
know there's like so many books i want
to write and papers i want to write and
you know things i want to learn that i
don't yet know
that i could easily imagine living for
another 200 years and not doing nearly
everything that i want to do so there's
a kind of rush to get things done in
some sense um but at the same time at
some point you want to enjoy life and
i'm actually not that bad at enjoying
life like i'm not a workaholic who sort
of deprives oneself of you know leisure
time or anything like that but then that
just contributes to the fact that you're
working really hard when you're not
having the leisure time when you're not
uh watching movies or basketball games
or whatever it is and i'm not especially
disciplined either like you know i feel
like i waste some time and i'm very
productive at other times i'm fortunate
enough when it comes to writing or doing
science that you know i can go in bursts
right and different people work in
different ways but i'm the kind of
person who can be really unproductive
for long periods of time and then the
burst of activity and get a lot done and
you know so far so good kind of good you
know like i said i'm not one of the
world's five best physicists so maybe it
could be better if i were productive all
the time but you know i've done okay
and i'm appreciative of the fact that
other people seem to appreciate some of
the things that i do that makes me feel
good but as far as developing discipline
and having some technique or something
like that um no
no i really i really don't i muddle
through as best i can like i'm always
like people who write books are always
asked about like their writing process
you know like do you wake up at six a.m
and meditate and then you know write for
an hour and then answer emails and
that's just not my life at all like
every day might be completely different
process-wise like i need to write when
i'm inspired to write when i'm ready to
write i can't force it on some schedule
or in some routine maybe it'll be better
if i had a routine and did that but but
i just don't
as far as sid's question goes
imposter syndrome was never
the right way to say it you know um
uh
you know i think like i'm i'm like i
said pretty good at physics but not as
good as the absolute best people in the
world and i think that is correct
syndrome that's just that's more or less
accurate i i don't feel like i'm
imposter i think there are people uh who
i'm
better than at and people who i'm worse
than at i didn't construct that sentence
very well because like i said i don't
like talking about myself
but um
you know i am an odd duck in some ways
uh you know i obviously i have a podcast
so if nothing else that makes me very
unusual in this set of all theoretical
physicists
and
i write physics papers which makes me
very unusual in the set of all
podcasters even about physics
so you know it's always been an awkward
fit and i've never been you know a big
non-academic family big public high
school
middle the road catholic university etc
it's always been you know me trying to
find my own ways in ways that
my environment didn't always
train me for in the best ways it was
certainly never something where this was
all expected to happen
and for better or for worse i just
wanted to do things in my own quirky
ways like
when i was at chicago i eventually got
denied tenure at the university of
chicago and i'll be very honest that i
worked hard and wrote papers and some of
those papers became super highly cited
but i didn't like devote myself to
getting tenure i didn't just say like i
didn't live in fear of not getting
tenure i just thought obviously i will
get tenure what's the problem i'm doing
good work i'm writing good papers what
is the thing to worry about and in
retrospect that was pretty dumb on my
part right but
it is you know how i live my life i
would like to do things like i would
like to do them and i've been
extraordinarily fortunate enough to
mostly get away with it that was one
example where i didn't get away with it
in a very big and loud and noisy and uh
impactful way uh but otherwise i i've
i've done okay so
um i don't think it's imposter syndrome
like i've never like i know that there
are people who are better than physics
than i am but i don't think that's
like a psychological mistake i think
that's just true and i admire those
people i try to learn from them rather
than feeling like i don't belong with
them because i do think i'm better than
them at other things
um
you know and there's probably people who
are better at
than i am at everything but i don't yeah
those people i don't run into that often
you know i'm lucky enough that for most
people even if they're better at me at
99 of the things i care about there's
one thing that i'm better at than maybe
it's just like playing poker or i don't
know making stir fries or something
there's got to be something right so
that's how i avoid getting too much
imposter syndrome in my life
einar venmir says priority question
why is the uncertainty principle not
enough to explain the collapse of the
wave function at measurement in quantum
physics a measurement of a quantum
property means to amplify a phenomenon
from the microscopic atomic domain to
the classical domain to amplify means to
add a substantial amount of energy to
the microscopic domain to make it
noticeable in the classical domain
when adding energy to one of a
superposition of quantum states the
object being measured will have an
uncertainty in its energy this is
determined by the added energy the
uncertainty in energy will imply an
uncertainty in the lifetime of the
superposed state through the uncertainty
principle causing the superposed state
to decay quickly into one state uh no so
i don't think it works at all sorry
about that inar for many reasons for one
thing
to amplify a microscopic quantum
superposition
to a macroscopic quantum superposition
has nothing to do with energy whatsoever
you don't need to put energy into this
system at all and the classic example is
schrodinger's cat right where you
amplify the superposition of a decaying
nucleus to a superposition of a cat but
the point is not that you put energy
into the cat the the awake cat and the
asleep cat have the same amount of
energy roughly speaking it's just that
they're in a macroscopically a
superposition of two macroscopically
different things and that's absolutely
typical of quantum mechanical
superpositions there need not be some
large energy difference between the two
parts of the superposition so you need
not add any energy at all to put things
into a superposition that's one thing
uh second thing is you say at the end
you know there's uncertainty in energy
that implies an uncertainty a lifetime
and the superimposed state will decay
quickly
but that's already assuming an answer to
the measurement problem like
superimposed states don't decay quickly
they evolve according to the schrodinger
equation unless
you have some theory of the measurement
that then collapses the wave function
onto one thing or the other that's what
we call a decay so when you observe a
geiger counter click because some
nucleus decayed that is a measurement of
the system that has collapsed the wave
functions you need already a theory of
the collapse of the wave function before
you can talk about that
finally
in some very real sense the uncertainty
principle is not about measurements at
all okay so you really in principle
can't bootstrap your way up from the
uncertainty principle to a theory of the
measurement problem because the
measurement
problem has to do with the fact that
there is a set of processes under which
wave functions appear to not obey the
schrodinger equation
they appear to collapse right and so
either they don't obey the schrodinger
equation or they just appear not to
because as everett would say you're not
observing the whole wave function
but the uncertainty principle isn't
about that it's not about the
measurement process it's about the
existence of quantum states without even
measuring them
certain quantum states just don't exist
there exist no quantum states where
there is a perfectly your the technical
way of saying it is you cannot be in an
eigen state a state of perfect
determination of both position and
momentum at the same time because there
are no states like that
um and that is i did not use the word
measurement anywhere in that statement
that i just made there are consequences
for measurement of the uncertainty
principle obviously
that's not surprising
but it's fundamentally a statement about
the fact that there's a relationship
between momentum and position that you
that if one is perfectly uh fixed the
other one is perfectly uncertain that's
it nothing to do with measurements
blake brasher says on a somewhat recent
podcast you mentioned that we shouldn't
think of the nucleus of an atom as being
composed of discrete protons and
neutrons but rather as a swirling mass
of quarks without any distinct
boundaries between the quarks
does this mean that the neutron stars
are actually giant blobs of quark soup
or is it also wrong to think of a
neutron star as being the same thing as
an atomic nucleus um
you know this is way too down to earth
physics for me to really be an expert so
i believe that the answer is yes it does
mean the neutron stars are actually
giant blobs of quark soup
and this is a
part of the weirdness of quantum
mechanics there is going to be a
lowest energy wave function for a
certain collection of up and down quarks
that is also feeling of gravity you know
if it has enough uh mass to have an
appreciable gravitational field
such that that lowest energy state looks
like a neutron star so it's not um that
there's individual neutrons bumping up
against each other because there's a
lower energy configuration
than that and the system will settle
into that
at least that's what i think on the
basis of my basic physics knowledge but
i don't know nearly enough about the
details of neutron stars you should ask
a real neutron star person or maybe even
google it i honestly don't know
simon kitt says
priority question is the discussion
research of consciousness an example of
strong emergence
as much as i struggle with the strong
emergence concept i find it hard to have
a coherent picture of endeavors to
understand consciousness that don't
involve some top-down causal power
i can't imagine a race of philosophical
zombies having this field of inquiry
what could possibly be causing
discussion research into the nature of
consciousness if not consciousness
itself
um
no
i don't think it is an example of strong
emergence so you know you've already
undermined your own question when you
say i can't imagine a race of
philosophical zombies having this field
of inquiry remember by definition
zombies behave in precisely the same way
as non-zombies do so every book that a
non-zombie would write could also be
written by a zombie every discussion
every field of inquiry
every passionate defense of the redness
of red and the experience thereof
would be
done by a zombie just as much as it
would be done by a conscious person and
this is why i don't think the people who
advocate the zombie thought experiment
really think it through for example for
exactly this reason
but
i don't think that you know strong
emergence is a slightly ill-defined
concept because it's kind of defined
negatively right you say that uh i have
a theory
and of small constituents making up a
bigger system and i have a theory of how
the small constituents behave
and if i put that theory of how the
small constituents behave on a computer
and simulated it
what it would predict for the collection
of all those constituents is different
from what happens when i actually
physically get those constituents
together in other words it's just a
statement that your theory of the small
constituents is insufficient is
incomplete is not enough to say what
happens when all these constituents come
together that's a strong emergence
as i talked about in the podcast with
philip goff and keith frankish there's
no room for that if your microscopic
theory is the standard model of particle
physics particles don't have
particles behave locally in space and
they respond locally to what fields are
doing at the same point in space where
the particles are
so there's no nothing
no way within that theory unless you
want to change the laws of physics which
is you know good for you try to do that
but if you don't change the known laws
of physics
strong emergence is not going to happen
from the level of particle physics to
the level of human beings
the question you're asking is a you know
i think
you put it best in the the final
line what could be causing discussion
and research into the nature of
consciousness if not consciousness
itself
well sure the research is being done by
conscious creatures there is no you know
school of consciousness research that is
populated by researchers who are not
themselves conscious that's true
but this is not something that is in any
way in conflict with the idea that
conscious creatures are just collections
of physical particles obeying the laws
of physics right uh your brain is a
thinking machine and is thinking about
itself among other things and you know
there's a very good article recently
in
where was it i don't know but i tweeted
it out um it was by janae ismail
previous podcast guest
and the reason why i treated it out
tweeted out not only because it was a
good article but because the headline on
the article was abysmally bad the
headline was something like you know
physics is wrong
human beings play a crucial role in the
cosmos and of course janan would never
say something like that and those words
are nowhere to be found in the actual
article what she was saying was
there is a problem
uh well not not a problem even but a a
feature of how we describe the world
that
needs to be taken into account the fact
that we are in the world okay so it's a
self-reference problem it's not a
problem of uh incompleteness of the laws
of physics but it's a problem of you
know one of these famous philosophy
problems of a uh if you're able to
completely predict the future right if
you're a prophet
if you or if your laplace is a demon
uh but then if you know what's going to
happen in the future because you can
predict it what happens if you do
something else what happens if you
violate the prediction right this is
always the problem with time travel
stories or profit stories or whatever
and the answer is that you know real
physical systems are not completely
accurate predictors about the future
they model the universe and they do
their best and janan's point was that in
that model of the universe needs to be a
model of you
because you can affect the universe but
your model of you is always going to be
crude you don't have enough capacity to
model yourself perfectly right i mean
this is my way now i'm translating now
i'm riffing on what janan said but
that's the basic point um so
but that's not an obstacle to describing
yourself at all there's an obstacle to
describing the world perfectly given
that you're in it
but we never try to describe the world
perfectly as we talked about earlier in
the ama we use heuristics we use
coarse-grained descriptions of the world
and they're always going to leave wiggle
room that's why there is something that
is useful to call our ability to make
choices and have volition and have free
will in the world but there's nothing
about any of that that makes you think
that it would be impossible to describe
all that in terms of purely physical
motion of matter as far as i can see
okay
i'm going to group two questions
together
james nencaro says why don't we know the
actual size of the universe i understand
that it may be our observable universe
is only what we can see and there is
likely matter further away beyond our
horizon but doesn't the microwave
background or early universe
nucleosynthesis allow some scaling of
the universe's total size that is does
the proportion of primordial hydrogen
and helium determine the total amount of
matter the bigger the universe the more
time for cooking up more helium at the
start
and then alexander mirage says
alexander sorry alexander mirage i think
you mentioned in one of the previous
amas that the universe while obviously
being super small at the beginning and
during the inflationary epoch could have
been infinite in size right after
inflation ended i heard professor alan
guth saying many times that our universe
could have been the size of a big marble
or a baseball at the end of the
inflationary period
taking this piece of information on
board did i get your point wrong more
broadly when we say that our universe
could be infinite in size either right
after inflation or today i get confused
do we mean our universe which is
prague's opinion was once the size of a
marble or some other broader reality
okay so there's a couple of different
things going on here one is
you know cosmologists are often sloppy
when they talk about the universe you
would think that they would be precise
when talking about the universe it's
their job it's what they do for a living
but in fact they're sloppy
sometimes when you say the universe you
mean the collection of everything
absolutely everything the whole shebang
what we see what we don't see the whole
bit
other times we just mean our observable
universe
in fact it's probably more frequent when
a cosmologist talks about the universe
and says oh there's 10 to the 88th
particles in the universe they mean our
observable part
of the universe they mean our observable
radius of the horizon that we're able to
see out to so
that is the part that when we say the
universe
at the end of inflation was the size of
a marble or a baseball
uh that's what we're talking about we're
only talking about the observable part
of the universe we're not necessarily
talking about the whole thing the whole
thing could be either
pretty much that size and maybe a little
bit bigger but not too much or it could
be infinitely big we just don't know
there are theoretical models either way
and there's zero experimental data
because we can't see outside our
observable universe by the nature of
what it means to be the observable
universe so
all the things that um alan guth was
saying about the size of the universe
refers to the observable universe my
statement um
you know so you said
the universe was super small at the
beginning and during the inflationary
universe but could have been infinite in
size right after and
right after inflation ended so i didn't
say that or if i did say that i
certainly didn't mean that what i might
have said what i have said sometimes is
that
at the moment of the big bang
which is a hypothetical singularity
which is really just a way of saying it
there is no singularity that we just
don't know what's happening but if you
just naively trace the equations
backward there's a singularity and
that's the big bang
it's impossible to define the size of
the universe at the big bang because of
singularity it just means your equations
are breaking down and you don't know
what's going on
but at any time after the big bang the
universe could have been infinitely big
that's completely compatible with
everything we know about general
relativity so the big bang could be the
beginning of an infinitely big universe
it doesn't need to start at some finite
size and expand okay so it's nothing to
do with inflation whatsoever that's just
a feature of general relativity that the
whole universe could come into existence
infinitely big when it's there
uh and that's not our observable
universe of course our observable
universe was marble-sized or whatever it
was
and then for james's question um
i i got mixed up there in the middle of
your question because
cmb and nucleosynthesis and things like
that all these data points we have from
the early universe they are completely
independent of the size of the universe
they had nothing to do with the size of
the universe what they have to do is
with the local density and expansion
rate and temperature of the universe so
the cmb and the nucleosynthesis result
from microphysical processes of you know
protons and neutrons fusing or electrons
being captured by nuclei things like
that right things that happen in points
in space
and they depend on the local conditions
the temperature the density etc but they
don't know how big the universe is the
cmb and nuclear synthesis would happen
exactly the same way in a finite sized
universe and an infinite size universe
with the same temperature and density
everywhere
okay thomas prunty says in your podcast
with david wallace you guys had a bit of
a disagreement about how to think about
the low entropy of the big bang
he said something like the early
universe had as high an entropy as it
could have given that it was uniform and
you said that uniformity is a huge
constraint
i don't see why uniformity could be
surprising or neat explanation it seems
like a very simple and sensible boundary
condition i understand that it's low
entropy when gravity is considered but i
don't see how that implies that it's
unlikely in this case what am i missing
well you know in some sense this is all
just fuzzy talk like you know what
should the universe be what should be
surprising what demands explanation
right like who are we to say what the
universe should look like or be
surprised by um but i don't think that
the fact that something is simple
uh sorry let me go let me be a little
bit more definite than that
simplicity
is a very useful thing to keep in mind
when thinking about laws of physics
right dynamical rules that tell you how
systems evolve over time or something
like that
we found empirically through the history
of science that looking for such simple
rules is a very fruitful endeavor but
it's completely different in my mind to
think about conditions or configurations
that the universe can be in
that's not something where we have any
good reason to think a priori that the
configuration of stuff in the universe
should take a simple form
i don't see why that should be true
right
i
do see why it should be a high entropy
form and the answer is because there are
more ways to be high entropy than to be
low entropy if you just sort of randomly
consider all the different ways the
universe could be
many many many more of them are going to
be high entropy than to be low entropy
so that's not to say the universe can't
start out with a low entropy but it says
if it does start out with a low entropy
there should be some reason why there
should be some explanation that's a clue
that there's something about the
dynamics of the universe that you
haven't figured out yet and so
um you know
when david says the early universe had
as high entropy as it can given that it
was uniform that's true you know in some
sense uh it's not exactly true but it's
pretty darn close to be true but that
doesn't say that that that statement is
completely independent from whether or
not the fact that the early universe's
uniform
suggests that we need to think more
deeply about what was going on or should
just be the stopping point um i don't
see why the fact that the early versus
uniform should in any sense
be something where we go oh yeah well
what what else could it have been that's
a natural starting point um
the obvious thing to think about is
as hugh price likes to point out if you
imagine a collapsing universe if you run
the clock backwards a collapsing
universe does not become more and more
uniform as it collapses it becomes
lumpier as it collapses so that's the
arrow of time you know it's a very very
unusual weird finely tuned configuration
for the early universe to be so uniform
bijan warner says
here's a question on the relationship
between quantum mechanics and chaos
theory to what extent is the principle
of sensitive dependence on initial
conditions apply to quantum systems does
this framework matter at all or is there
something about quantum systems that
make this not an interesting thing to
ask
um this is a complicated question
actually and i'm not even an expert on
it so let me try to restrict what i say
to things i'm pretty sure are true okay
there's a whole subject called quantum
chaos
and here's the reason why it's a
non-trivial question because in
classical chaos classical systems are
often chaotic not always there are
non-chaotic classical systems but you
don't need to work very hard to get uh a
classical system that is chaotic like
you put a couple of pendulums and hang
them from each other and you get a
chaotic motion for the triple pendulum
as it is called
um
but quantum systems are a little bit
different because the reason why
classical systems can be chaotic has to
do with the non-linearity of the
interactions between them what i mean by
that is
linear is when everything just depends
on the variable you're looking at to the
power one right x to the first power
as soon as something depends on higher
powers you know x squared etc that's
non-linear and the difference is that
when you have a linear system
if you perturb it a little bit uh it
moves a little bit and that's it a small
perturbation leads to a small difference
in what is happening but when you have a
non-linear system a small perturbation
can grow very rapidly and that's where
you get chaos that's where you get
sensitive dependence on initial
conditions because the the tiny
perturbation you give it can feed on
itself and grow very very quickly
in classical mechanics
the fundamental equations of motion are
often non-linear in quantum mechanics
the schrodinger equation
itself is linear
okay
the schrodinger equation has a wave
function as its fundamental variable and
the wave function appears to the power
one on both sides of the schrodinger
equation one side is
the
hamiltonian which is asking how much
energy is there and it says h
operating on one power of psi the wave
function
the other side is the time derivative
how fast is the wave function changing
acting on one power of the wave function
so the kind of evolution that is chaotic
in classical systems naively doesn't
appear at all in quantum mechanical
systems the wave function itself does
not
evolve chaotically
full stop
but of course
in quantum mechanics we have a classical
limit right and this is where it becomes
a subject that needs require requires a
study and papers written about it and
why this whole thing called quantum
chaos because
even though the wave function evolves
linearly and non-chaotically
the classical observables the classical
limit of that wave function
you know gives rise to classical
mechanics the quantum the the triple
pendulum that is a chaotic system is a
classical limit of some quantum system
right so there has to be some classical
limit of this quantum system that does
behave non-linearly and chaotically okay
so there is an interesting thing to talk
about
which is this relationship between the
underlying behavior of the wave function
and the emergent classical world and the
emergence of nonlinearities in that
classical world so i'm not going to say
anything specific about that but that is
an interesting intersection overlap to
talk about
okay andrew vickerstaff says many recent
mindscape episodes have looked at the
fallibility of human thought processes
and how susceptible we all can be to
bias manipulation and irrational ideas
given that we understand this problem
today much more than we did say 20 years
ago and given the exponential growth and
misinformation the average person is now
exposed to do you think that the jury
system in its current form is still a
fair way to decide criminal trials in
particular do you have any thoughts on
the jury selection process in america
and whether or not it helps or hinders
the justice system
that's an interesting you know um
thing to put together you know the jury
system that came out of hundreds of
years ago
it was thought to be important that
people were tried by a jury of their
peers now there's well-known issues
there because only you know
property-owning white men were
considered people uh at the time in
terms of who got to vote and who got to
serve on the juries and all that stuff
uh but nevertheless the idea was that it
was a participatory part of the
democratic process that deciding guilt
or innocence
should not be led to a professional
elite but
should involve the participation of the
common people
in part a reflection of going way back
to ancient greece you know in
socrates's trial
everyone in athens who wanted to be part
of the jury could be part you know they
all came and they all voted if they
wanted to
we don't do it quite that badly uh and
but by the way you know uh for those of
you who are not in the u.s
uh in the u.s there is a right to trial
by jury we say there's a right to trial
by jury in fact it's only for
sufficiently serious crimes like if you
get a parking ticket you do not have a
right to trial by jury for that
um
but just because there's a right doesn't
mean people take it
in fact jury trials are a tiny
percentage of all of the
legal actions going on in the legal
system at any one point uh you know sort
of the big ticket corporate
legal procedures don't even go to trial
right i mean you can sue somebody but
they're usually just settled out of
court after it becomes clear who will
win at court
and even in in criminal defense uh
situations you can easily just have a
judge trial you don't need to have a
jury trial it's a something that the
defendant can request under appropriate
circumstances so juries are not a big
part of the criminal justice system
overall
um
i certainly
appreciate the problems with the fact
that uh
people who appear on a jury are not
going to be you know uh experts right
they're they're chosen specifically not
to be experts but i think that and i'm
not so i'm not an expert on this but
here's my feeling and then you know real
experts can let us know
um there's both good and bad aspects of
that okay i mean one aspect that is good
is just the fact that it is
participation
just the fact it is a reminder to the
people on the jury that they play a role
in the government that the
act of governing their country including
judging people's
guilt or innocence in a court of law
is not
purely the domain of some distant elites
it is something that every day citizens
have some role in doing um you know so
that there's some civic virtue kind of
aspect to it that way
um
and then the other from the other side
from the point of view of
the defendants etc you know
i think it's the case that usually
juries take their jobs pretty seriously
right
um you know it's an interesting
phenomenon i talked about this with
astra taylor when she was on the podcast
the
political system called sortition
where it's government or not if not the
whole government at least certain
decisions being made not even by voting
but by just a random selection of people
are chosen to sit and think about an
issue so not the guilt or innocence of
some criminal defendant but you know a
law right should this be a law or not so
sortition says we're going to pick some
random representatives from the
population let them sit and think about
it and what you find is that when people
are put into that situation they usually
take it really seriously that doesn't
mean they're good at it necessarily they
still have their own biases etc
um
we're not always very good at making
sure that all of the representative
voices are heard on juries and things
like that but
there are some surprisingly uplifting
features of that kind of situation so i
don't so clearly juries do the wrong
thing sometimes that's absolutely true
100
um
but i'm not at all convinced i don't
know enough to have any strong feelings
about but certainly i'm not at all
convinced that we would have a better
system overall uh if we didn't have
juries like you know judges and lawyers
can be bad too right even though they
are professionals so i i don't i would
need to see
actual data-based uh evidence-based
studies that are trying to be very fair
about whether or not juries overall make
things worse or better i really don't
know
brandon lewis says do you imagine that
you will use quantum computing in your
research once they become available to
you and mature enough to be useful and
if so what kinds of problems would they
help you to solve
um
i mean probably not is the short answer
you know the research that i do is very
pencil and paper i do some
minor computer simulations like in the
paper i wrote with ash meat singh on
dividing up quantum systems into
subsystems we did a little example right
a little toy example with some simple
harmonic oscillators and we put on a
computer and simulated it and in
principle on a quantum computer that
would be way more efficient right that's
what quantum computers are really good
at is simulating quantum systems and so
in that sense
some of my research projects would be
good fits for quantum computation but
i'm a little skeptical that you're gonna
get
very powerful quantum computers like
that uh at least in an affordable way
anytime soon by which i mean like my
research career okay
i'm a little i'm a little skeptical that
you know we're going to build up a lot
of qubits and have just so much capacity
that people are going to have quantum
laptops or something like that you know
i'm not at the level of using super
computers even right now so i don't
think that we'll ever get to the level
of needing a quantum computer for my
research more than people who are really
doing you know
quantum quantum field theory simulating
on a quantum computer or chemistry on a
quantum computer those are the kinds of
things that would be higher priority
than little old me
peter b says a priority question you've
discussed before how the many worlds of
quantum mechanics may be just the other
side of the same coin as the
cosmological multiverse i'm still
struggling to understand this idea i can
understand how i am in a superposition
with other versions of me in the quantum
multiverse but how can i be in a
superposition with other versions of me
trillions of light years away or are you
saying that these types of multiverses
redundantly contain the same set of
events but they're still distinct from
each other
um well this is a subtle thing so i
guess i've discussed it before but
probably not very often because it is a
very subtle thing i have a blog post
about it that goes into more detail
this was an idea
that uh you know
however many years ago before these two
papers came out two papers came out one
by yasen arena mora
and the other by rafael buso and lenny
suskind
and they both were on along very similar
lines drawing a connection between the
cosmological multiverse and the many
worlds of quantum mechanics and before
that if you would ask me i would say no
they're obviously very very different
they have nothing to do with each other
but the missing ingredient which is
highly non-trivial is the idea of
horizon complementarity okay
uh which is a little complicated but
this is a priority question so you're
you're it was good that you put priority
question in here because otherwise i
might have skipped over it because this
is complicated to explain but the idea
is the following
[Music]
due to susken and some of his
collaborators first in the context of
black holes you know they were trying to
understand the black hole information
loss puzzle and there's certain features
of classical black hole physics that are
a little bit puzzling not super puzzling
but a little bit uh counterintuitive at
face value if you throw something into a
black hole right you know the famous
thing to say for the information loss
puzzles throw a book into a black hole
the information falls in it disappears
classically that would be fine but
quantum mechanically it evaporates away
how does the information get out
but we all know because there is
something called gravitational time
dilation that from the point of view of
the outside observer
at least in some
approximation where the book does not
have its own mass or something like that
but the book you don't see the book
disappear past the event horizon right
what you see is the book move more and
more slowly as it comes close to the
event horizon the book doesn't feel that
way if you were writing the book if you
fell in with a book you would just pass
right through the event horizon but from
the point of view of an outside observer
it just seems to slow down and approach
creep up closer and closer to it
so suskin and friends said well maybe
there's like a souped-up quantum version
of this
which says that there's one thing that
is going on
in the world but there are two different
ways of talking about it that depend on
which observer you are there's the
observer that falls in and everything is
just perfectly normal and to the
observer far away
all of what falls into the black hole
all the information that falls into the
black hole is somehow stuck on the
horizon
okay
and this is an incompatible picture but
that's why it's called complementarity
because you get to choose you can't
describe it both ways at the same time
you can either
describe it from the point of view of
the in-falling observer or the distant
observer but not both okay
there's a version of this idea that
works for cosmology if you're in an
accelerating universe like we're in
right
uh then you have a horizon around you
that horizon approaches a fixed size and
so the horizon complementarity view of
cosmology would be
that there is no outside universe
this is kind of there's there's
different versions of this idea i'm
telling you the most radical hardcore
version okay the most radical version is
there's the universe we see from inside
and what you and i think of as the
external universe
all of its information is just on our
horizon there's nothing more to it than
that okay but that includes everything
that you might have been tempted to say
is outside our observable universe it's
all just encoded on our horizon and
that's a finite amount of information
that you need that would ever be
relevant to describing the outside world
okay what does that have to do with many
worlds and the multiverse
well it would seem
that taking that idea at face value
rules out the multiverse right you're
saying that there is no
universe extending infinitely far away
there's just our horizon
but now remember there's the many worlds
interpretation of quantum mechanics and
in these cosmological theories of the
multiverse what you're imagining is
there are quantum mechanical transitions
between different vacuum states that
would look like different local laws of
physics
so
much like a decaying nucleus or let's
say just just pick an individual neutron
out there in space a neutron can decay
we say into a proton an electron an
anti-neutrino
in a correct many worlds version of that
story we say that the neutron wave
function evolves into a superposition of
a neutron plus
proton electron and anti-neutrino in a
very similar way the universe evolves in
a sup into a superposition of our vacuum
state plus other vacuum states
and in all of them according to this
version of the story
there's a horizon and the horizon has a
certain size and that's the whole
universe
so
what this theory says is that the
cosmological multiverse still exists in
the presence of horizon complementarity
but it exists because of the many
different branches of the wave function
all the different
parts of the universe
where there's different local laws of
physics are sitting on top of each other
at the same point in space in some
ill-defined sense but all the branches
of the wave function
describe individually finite sized
cosmological horizon size patches
okay that's the story so you can sort of
instantiate the cosmological multiverse
in one patch of space-time by evoking
the many worlds of quantum mechanics
that's the idea is the idea right yeah
we don't know we have no idea this is
this is you know doing our best to draw
conclusions from sketchy
uh assumptions about how both gravity
and quantum mechanics work so it's
possible but i couldn't tell you whether
it's right or not
matt hickman asks a priority question to
it can i have another priority question
please uh nope you can't that's the
whole idea the priority question you
only get one so you should use it wisely
or you should have used it wisely
however you want to parse that rebecca
lashua says you've mentioned in the past
that if you weren't a theoretical
physicist you would consider being a
theoretical computer scientist are there
any particular results in the theory of
computation that you find interesting or
aesthetically pleasing
uh you know it's very vague because i'm
not a theoretical computer scientist but
i find fascinating you know the
restrictions on computability and
computation and
as we discussed before in the ama
um all of the structure that sort of
comes to life because of our boundedness
and finitude right and this has to do
with emergence and things like that that
i am working on so
in john conway's game of life the famous
cellular automata with the black and
white squares on the checkerboard um
there's a sense of emergence in that
game right because there are structures
like gliders and glider guns that you
can talk about
as individual phenomena without
specifying the specific details of every
little black and white square
so you know in some sense
in some sense
theoretical computer science has
something to do with artificial worlds
and you can study general principles of
dynamics or emergence or things like
that in the context of these artificial
worlds and then worry later about
applying it to our world as a physicist
i kind of got to worry about our world
that's my job but as a theoretical
computer scientist you're less
constrained so i think that's the kind
of thing i'd be interested in but you
know who knows maybe i would be doing
artificial intelligence or
something like that there's a it's a
whole new brand new world that we're
inventing in that whole field so many
many interesting questions out there
peter c harris says do you have any
thoughts about the 1619 project in the
new york times decision to endorse it
my understanding is that the person
leading the project is a brilliant
journalist but not a historian and
historian
peter correctly wrote sorry i
mispronounced it and that many
historians including african-american
ones say the project contains
significant historical errors isn't this
roughly analogous to a science
journalist creating a project that
endorses the copenhagen interpretation
of quantum mechanics and having that
project endorsed by the times even
though credible rival interpretations
such as many worlds exist should a
newspaper record even be making such
endorsements um i think the short answer
i try to give the short answer to long
questions first so the short answer is
no i i don't uh quite um agree with
where you're going here um and i don't
even think that it's correct to
formulate it as saying the new york
times has endorsed this the new york
times published
the 1619 project just like it publishes
you know
op-ed pieces and book reviews and news
articles and a whole bunch of other
things that it published um and
certainly it it rose to the level of
being publishable in the new york times
uh but i but i think that the framing is
a little bit off i would say at least my
opinion versus your opinion i would
frame it a little bit differently um
the 1619 project uh made a lot of claims
and some of them were mistakes
that's not surprising to me at all you
know like any big project i've written
books you know as someone who writes
books a couple of mistakes will creep
into those that that is by itself
not really determinative anything at all
um i do think there's a slightly more uh
pointed critique you could make that
maybe some of the mistakes they made
were you know the direction of the
mistake was influenced by an underlying
political perspective that they had i
think that's a better criticism to make
that they you know aired
uh there were systematic errors and not
just random ones let's put it that way
and that's okay it's a perfectly good
criticism
but to me that criticism completely
pales in comparison to what they're
trying to do to the bigger picture point
of view of what they're trying to do
look any society any country any nation
uh tells stories about itself
history is a set of stories that we
choose to tell the number of facts about
the past that we could potentially write
down is infinitely big
the whole thing about history is we pick
some of those facts to focus on and to
tell as stories and to relate to
ourselves and unsurprisingly
countries nations
tend to tell more or less flattering
stories about themselves
they tend to gloss over the parts that
are a little bit less flattering right
like japan doesn't really like to talk
about what happened in manchuria at the
beginning of world war ii they don't
really like to talk about that right
um
france you know i have
friends who are french who really are
genuinely puzzled about why other people
from european nations don't like
napoleon i mean after all napoleon just
brought civilization to them and the
rule of law shouldn't they be thankful
to napoleon uh british people are
genuinely puzzled that people around the
world
mind that they were colonized again you
know weren't they just bringing uh peace
and love to them they don't get it
because we tell uh these stories about
ourselves that you know in china any
any idea about tiananmen square has been
scrubbed
clean right
and the united states is no different
than that the united states
tends to in its sort of uh history
lessons etc teach a sanitized version of
the real history you know there's plenty
of examples the trail of tears is a
terrible
uh awful
uh incident in the united states history
which is not put front and center
certainly when i was in high school
maybe it's different now
um maybe a more well-known example is
the
controversies over columbus day right
by any even halfway objective
uh judgment christopher columbus was a
terrible terrible person i mean he was a
genocidal rapist uh racist maniac
um and he also you know had some ships
that you know traveled across the ocean
i mean even that his spanish sponsors
got completely tired of him by the end
of it but
no objective uh historical account of
what columbus did would paint him as a
hero
uh but you know there's a story in the
united states that uh you know
discovered america and you know we
brought civilization to it and this is
not
you know just from uh hundreds of years
ago i remember when i was growing up we
had uh schoolhouse rock which was great
mostly schoolhouse rock were these
little cartoons you would watch on
saturday mornings that would teach you
about
different educational things sometimes
about grammar or science but sometimes
about history and there is one called
elbow room about how you know when the
colonists came from europe to the united
states they needed elbow room they
needed space so they basically spread
across the country and everyone was
happy
that's a story
that we're telling that leaves out
certain aspects of the story namely like
all the indigenous people who were
killed right and their theirs their
cultures wiped out in the process of
that expansion across the continent
and the idea of slavery
and its role in the
whole history of the united states is
one that absolutely we don't always face
up to in the united states and so the
goal of the 1619 project was to
put slavery front and center
as an aspect of what uh was being
thought about at the founding of the
united states and did they go too far
sometimes did they did they over
emphasize the role of slavery and you
know why the american colonies chose to
declare their independence from britain
and so forth
maybe very plausibly i'm not a political
expert there but look the point is
it's them versus the world you know it's
not like they're the only history of the
united states that's ever been written
uh they're going up against every other
single history of the united states
where the role of slavery has been under
emphasized you need a correction in
these situations and so good for them
for moving in that direction you know i
think that this is part of being honest
being uh
factual and evidence-based is that you
have to look at your
potential biases and this goes for
countries just as well as it goes for
individuals
you want to tell a story of your past
that makes you look good right and this
again for societies as well as for
individuals
and the united states has been just
really really uh
it's consistently failed
to
examine the role of slavery in the
history of the united states you know we
talk about the civil war
plenty of people in the south still
think you know the the south was that
the confederacy was virtuous in one way
or another and they try to tell
themselves stories about how it really
wasn't about slavery and things like
that and so
you know i am perfectly willing to
criticize factual mistakes that are made
by the 1619 project or anywhere else but
the project is well worth taking
seriously you know we need to examine
our flaws and again this is part of
being honest and truthful and
factually based we need to be able to
face up
to the parts of our history personally
and nationally and humanly
that are make us the least comfortable
it's not always an easy thing to do but
i i applaud them for pushing us in that
direction
paul cousin says
the last episode with tyden a bradley
was fascinating in it you discussed the
philosophical question of whether it
could be conceivable to find all the
semantics and the statistics of the
words alone
would it make the idea more realistic if
we include in these statistics all the
sensory inputs that humans receive from
the world while experiencing words in
which case a machine would be strongly
limited in its abilities to understand
language unless
we provide contextual sensory
information as well in the data set what
do you think
again this is something where i don't
have thoughts that
are necessarily a very expert level okay
this is a the kind of question that
people take very very seriously in ai
robotics uh
language studies linguistics etc uh
semantics semiotics
um so but let me just say that
you know maybe in principle you would
get a different
view of the role of language and how it
was used if you coupled it to
observations of the outside world so you
look at not only what words are being
said but in what context those words are
said what is going on in the world
around you what data you have in front
of you when you say those words
sure i mean that's more data right so it
gives you a better view of the world but
it also sort of pulls the rug out from
underneath the dramatic claim that is
being made which in some sense there's a
claim being made which is that you don't
really need that extra information and
that claim could be true or false
but the idea is that there is enough
information
just in the
relationships between words and how they
appear
that it greatly constrains the possible
meanings of those words even if you
don't know what the person is looking at
or talking about or whatever so
yeah you might be able to get even
better understanding by adding more
stuff in but the question is can you get
a really really good understanding
without it i think that's the that is
the issue that is trying to be addressed
by this research and again the answer
might be yes or no or yes sometimes and
no other times
but that's what they're trying to do
naive alam says which genre of music do
you consider to be your favorite do you
have any interest in opera
say by wagner strauss or mozart
so i'm pretty
uh ecumenical in my musical taste like i
like music overall i like all sorts of
different kinds of music um
but you know classical music is
something where i'm not an expert like i
know that there are
layers there that i am not sufficiently
uh discerning or familiar enough to
really uh talk about or judge in in any
uh reliable way so i'm very happy to go
to the opera and enjoy it but i'm not
going to claim to be appreciating the
nuances that a real expert would
uh be able to experience um you know
somewhere between jazz and classic rock
are my favorite genres of music you know
i grew up in the 70s i guess uh my
formative musical years 70s early 80s
and you know that and i like the music
of the 60s in the early 70s and and in
popular music-wise so i mean that's my
bread and butter and then later on i
discovered jazz and would go to jazz
clubs and i really do
love jazz probably you know
maybe a little bit more even than rock
and roll but um
you know and everyone from
mingus to thelonious monk to a whole
bunch of people there's a reason why and
wynton marsalis is one of my first
podcast guests um
uh but you know
i'm not i i don't i'm not very judgy
about music i i'm not
you know it would be weird since i'm not
even a moral realist for me to be an
aesthetic realist i don't think there is
a fact of the matter about what music is
good and what music is bad music is what
moves you i mean well what matters about
music to me is what moves you
personally like you can like and enjoy
the simplest dumbest bubble gum pop
music as far as i'm concerned i don't i
do not think any less of you for that i
don't think it's wrong
to like that okay
uh if it brings you pleasure then that's
great and there's no special
accomplishment in liking the weirdest
most challenging music like it's good if
you like it that's cool but doesn't make
you better than anybody else you know
liking john cage is not intrinsically
superior to liking britney spears or
whatever it is whatever comparison you
want to do
alex borland says do you have any
favorite restaurants in boston
especially in chinatown
um so yeah i debated whether to answer
this question because the answer is no i
don't i don't have any really super
favorite ones like but i wanted to just
remark on the fact that you know i look
i love boston this is why i'm spending
some time here and i spent eight years
of my life here living here
the restaurant scene man it's just not
just not up to snuff sorry you know
before this the two cities i lived in uh
or in between when i was here for grad
school and postdoc and now
uh the two cities i lived in the longest
were chicago and los angeles both of
which in their ways are amazing food
towns
weirdly chicago is is great for fine
dining you know for like three star
michelin star restaurants kind of things
alina which is arguably one of the
world's greatest restaurants is there
and there's plenty of other restaurants
sort of in that stratosphere for you
know getting dressed up a little bit
spending a lot of money um chicago is
just amazingly good and it's not even a
lot of money to be honest like there are
cities that are a lot more expensive
than that whereas los angeles the sort
of street food ethnic food you know a
variety of different cuisines and
different mixtures is is unprecedented
in my experience and of course there's
other cities you know new york and san
francisco and whatever that have amazing
food scenes and in their own ways new
orleans and uh austin or other places
around the us
and boston is fine
it's okay then you look i live in
chinatown right now from
live for a couple months and uh you know
i'm surrounded by dumplings so many
dumplings so many hot pot restaurants a
few noodle restaurants and they're fine
um
there's a little bit of variety there's
a malaysian place that is the of the
ones i've sampled this malaysian place
is definitely the best but it's not like
transcendentally good right it's not
like you're going to get in the san
gabriel valley and if you're in los
angeles
um probably the i've been to a couple of
fine dining restaurants here in boston
and they were fine you know but
not as good as you get in las vegas in
vegas you get really good fine dining
much less chicago or new york
um
and you know probably the single best
restaurant experience i had was a place
called ruka
near chinatown um near downtown crossing
which is sort of like uh
it belongs in vegas honestly maybe maybe
it has an outpost in vegas it's like a
hip japanese slash peruvian fusion place
and that's the kind of you know recipe
for disaster if you do it badly but they
really do it well like the cold sesame
noodles um and the uh the rolls that
they had were really really top-notch i
gotta give ruka some uh some kudos there
or uka if you're near chinatown in
boston
justin bailey says what do you think is
this is the most credible explanation
for why we experience a single reality
in a branching universe
so i think this is one of those like
sneakily difficult but really
fascinating questions actually uh you
know if you
so i'm more hardcore about quantum
mechanics and and many worlds than even
most other many worlds people are than
like more than david wallace's in the
sense that i think that the ultimate way
to think about reality is a pure quantum
vector
not something that sort of is based on
some pre-existing classical precursor
theory so to me
the there's work to be done in
explaining why the world looks classical
at all more work than for most people
who sort of presume some classical
superstructure hidden in how they define
the correct theory of the world like
they put in space and fields or
particles or whatever i think that all
those have to emerge somehow from the
wave function so it's a tricky question
um why we experience a single reality so
first you have to say
why i mean there's different levels to
this question one is
how is it
that a classical looking world can
emerge from a quantum mechanical
underlying structure and i think that
there
seems to be a lot of prerequisites to
that you know the the underlying quantum
structure has to have a lot of
properties
that are necessary to allow for a
classical limit to exist so when you say
single reality
sorry let me back up there's just too
many things going on here with this
question so let me let me finish that
thought i was making um
only certain quantum theories will have
classical limits at all okay that is one
fact and we're still trying to
investigate that and understand it
better the other which i should have
said first is that
the word we
is sneakily important in this question
you ask why we experience a single
reality okay
so you know again if you were the
quantum version of laplace's demon you
could just talk about the wave function
in the universe you wouldn't need to
talk about branches or anything like
that
but everett's insight
is that when the branching happens
what occurs on one branch has no effect
whatsoever on what occurs on other
branches
so
that is a subset
of a sort of deeper principle
and i'm not sure what that deeper
principle is
this is why i think this is a good
research level question to ask
how given some big theory of everything
do you divide it up
uh into subsets which interact with each
other in some interesting way so that
they would count amongst themselves as a
separate world
okay
we have examples you know in the case of
many worlds when there's decoherence
it's pretty clear you can sort of point
to the reasons why
things that happen on one branch of the
wave function will not affect things
that happen on another branch
in the cosmological multiverse it's also
clear because and forget about all the
craziness we just talked about about
horizons and complementarity and things
like that in the naive picture of the
cosmological multiverse
where something is just trillions of
light years away you can't get to it so
that's a pretty straightforward reason
why you can't interact with it and
therefore you're part of a separate
universe self-contained kind of universe
but the general theory of that i don't
know i don't know what the general
statements are about when to divide
things up into different universes which
you would call like i cannot treat
myself and the table in front of me as
part of two different universes because
i can easily interact with it and the
fact that it can affect me right but i
don't know the general theory of that so
that's
point zero point one is
the way that
individual branches of a quantum wave
function uh become
separate worlds in this
sense is by being classical
is by uh being well approximated by the
rules of classical mechanics right like
we got along for hundreds of years in uh
human history describing the world's
the world with the rules of classical
mechanics pretty well right we didn't
need to know quantum mechanics quantum
mechanics
imposes itself in
unavoidable ways only when we get down
to the level of individual particles or
atoms right
why is that you know why are there
classical limits to the world and and
why do we need there to be classical
limits to call it a single world okay
um
and then finally
so
there's the question of
given a quantum
theory how do you get a classical limit
out of it that you would call a single
world then there's a very deep question
of why does the quantum theory of our
universe have the properties that are
required to give you a classical limit
at all why are we allowed to have a
classical limit i don't know that one
either right that's another set of rules
that we don't have written down yet so
all this is very difficult to answer
stuff so the vague answer to your
question is there is some feature of the
real world that is fundamentally quantum
mechanical but is amenable to an
emergent higher level description as a
series of parallel classical
approximations
why that's true or under what conditions
it could be true are things that we
don't really know very well
josh charles says when thinking about
the far-flung future
do we have an idea of how much matter
would escape going through the process
of entering a black hole and being
radiated back out
um
so i think what you mean is if you just
let the universe evolve for a long time
some matter is going to fall into black
holes and then be radiated away
eventually and some maybe won't
um
you know i'm sure this is a very
answerable question if you really sat
down and thought about it very carefully
you know there have been papers written
by fred adams and greg laughlin about
exactly these kinds of questions about
the ultra long-term fate of the universe
and i think the question is that most
matter falls into black holes if you
wait long enough um
some matter was just like flung out into
the space in between the black holes but
you know our galaxy for example
most particles in our galaxy are
gravitationally bound to the galaxy
right they're not just passing through
on hyperbolic orbits
and what that means is if you wait long
enough they will spiral into the black
hole at the center now you have to wait
a very very long time and the spiraling
in is caused both by um mixing between
different parts of the stars and gas and
dust in the galaxy by the emission of
gravitational waves by just cooling off
and emitting photons by a whole bunch of
different things
um plenty of things won't fall into
black holes plenty of photons will never
fall into black holes but i think most
of the actual massive particles in the
universe will eventually get there
that's my belief
don't ask me to do a calculation to test
it
zack mckinney says how do you see
differences in seemingly esoteric
philosophical and metaphysical questions
such as the nature of consciousness or
free will
translating into concrete and
consequential differences in how people
approach real-world problems and
conflicts
well
you know they do and they don't you know
uh i think some do and some don't i
think there's an obvious way in which
these uh deep philosophical esoteric
questions do have an effect on real
world outcomes namely
um
meta ethics
okay
so we have ethics which is your view of
what is right and what is wrong
we have meta ethics which is how you
justify your view of what is right and
what is wrong so if you say
do unto others as you would have them do
unto you that is an ethical precept
if you say uh there are universal rules
that everyone should follow that is a
meta-ethical precept and then the do
undo others is the ethical the actual
rule that you say everyone should follow
or if you should if you say um
uh you should be consequentialist that's
a meta-ethical
precept and then if you say here are the
consequences that matter and here's how
you add them up that is a specific
specific ethical way of doing things
so here's a meta-ethical perspective
do what god tells you to do
and i think if you had that in that
ethical perspective which many people in
the world do by the way
you might end up with different ethics
than people do who are more naturalist
about it theism versus naturalism is a
really important philosophical question
with very obvious
practical real world consequences
um
i've used this argument with friends
before that you know um
because a lot of physicists and
philosophers they tend to be atheists
right they tend to not be
theists they tend to be naturalists not
all of them there's obviously many
examples but many most are atheists but
they don't talk about it a lot you know
they don't
draw
a line from their scientific or
philosophical viewpoints to a public
declaration of
atheism or naturalism
and i you know i try to say that look
what we do for a living as theoretical
physicists or philosophers or whatever
this is sort of the implicit uh issue in
your question from zack
it doesn't have a lot of impact on
people's everyday lives right
you know you know whether or not
it's bohmian mechanics or i've already
in quantum mechanics right you know you
can go through your life pretty much
okay but the one example where it does
have an impact is in whether god exists
that has a big difference
and then so that's and you can sort of
fill in the gaps fill in the details
about how that might affect people's
behavior in the real world and then also
you know even if you specialize to
people who are naturalists
um i don't think that naturalists have
done a good job
of
telling people how to live or if you
don't want to be quite so prescriptive
of suggesting ways that we can find
meaning and purpose in our lives even
without god
there's some cliches that we bandy about
but really when you when you get right
down to it it's not quite as convincing
and full of a story and it could be and
should be
but uh you know we're still
we we've abandoned these sort of
underlying philosophical justifications
for a lot of the choices and modes of
life that we've had throughout human
history without actually changing the
modes because we haven't really thought
through what the implications should be
of this new view of the fundamental
nature of reality
um
look again you know i'm quoting a lot of
old podcasts here but go back to the
very first week of podcasts i did and i
talked to anthony pinn
who is an atheist uh theologian at rice
university
and also he's black and he cares a lot
about how the black community
is very religious and he thinks that
they should be
more atheist but he gets why they're not
and he says look you know you have
that black people get something out of
going to church out of being part of a
religious community and you can't just
tell them that the force of reason
is against their belief system you have
to give them a soft landing you have to
tell them how they can live just as
fulfilled and uh rewarding a life
without that religious superstructure
and you haven't he says you atheists who
he includes himself and myself among
them you haven't done that
so i think that you know even within
naturalism or atheism there's still a
lot of work to be done
in doing exactly what you are asking
about what are the everyday consequences
of this view of the world i mean how in
the world can you imagine
changing your completely deepest
fundamental nature of reality
without any consequences for you know
how you live your everyday life surely
there must be there we haven't done a
great job of explaining what those
differences are all right and the very
last question from sam buck is
now for something completely different
what's your favorite kind of sandwich
and so i'm going to you know i
helped myself to a few flattering
questions earlier actually i started
with an insulting question right about
the professor telling me that it was pop
philosophy but then there were some
flattering questions about how his
discipline and things like that so i
wanted to end with a self-deprecating
question because i do not have a
sophisticated theories of sandwiches
i think that's too bad you know maybe i
should have a sophisticated theory of
sandwiches but like my favorite
sandwiches are kind of the you know
down-to-earth everyday sandwiches like a
good tuna melt i like there's of course
the famous question about whether hot
dogs are sandwiches right but if they
were if you i don't have a strong
feeling about whether hot dogs are
sandwiches but if they were sandwiches
they would absolutely be some of my
favorites like a really good hot dog i
know a lot of people have never had good
hot dogs before that is part of the
chicago culinary scene is uh their hot
dogs like again
you know the east coast as much as i
love it and i grew up here
you know in boston or in new york for
that matter the street level food is
like you know the hot dogs just sitting
there in the lukewarm water
or the pizzas that they make
in the morning and then the pizzas sit
there cold uh for hours they will reheat
a slice for you and i'm like how do you
live like this this is just terrible in
chicago you grill that hot dog when you
order it and then it's it's a good hot
dog it tastes completely different even
in o'hare even in the airport in o'hare
i get a really good hot dog better than
i can get on the streets of new york by
far
anyway
cheesesteaks grew up in philadelphia
love a good cheesesteak
i like sandwiches i like the idea of
sandwiches i like them in in pita
uh you know one of the best hot dogs i
ever had was in paris of all places like
in a baguette with really good french
mustard
but i don't have a good sophisticated
theory of sandwiches i couldn't tell you
why certain sandwiches are good and
certain sandwiches are bad they're easy
they're good comfort food you can get a
lot of variety in every bite it's a good
system i'm pro sandwich i can go that
far even without telling you what the
best one is and with that uh we'll call
an end to the ama uh the final ama of
the year 2021 what a year it was in many
ways uh thank you once again as always
for supporting the mindscape podcast i
uh appreciate it very very much i hope
you're getting something out of it i'm
constantly kind of amazed that people
will go
with me on this journey through so many
different
questions and so many different fields
talking to so many different people it's
great fun and great privilege to me and
i'm glad you're coming along so take
care and for those of you who have
holidays in front of you have good
holidays give thanks be well
[Music]
you